Good evening, ladies and gentlemen. My name is Mark Zito, and on behalf of Sirius XM, I want to thank you so much for coming out to Stephen Talkhouse for a very special, very intimate episode of Smartless. We go. We go. We go. That's up. Welcome. Thank you for being here.
各位女士、各位先生，晚上好。我是马克·齐托，我谨代表天狼星XM广播公司，非常感谢大家来到斯蒂芬·托克豪斯参加这一期非常特别、非常私密的《Smartless》节目。我们开始了。开始了。开始了。就是这样。欢迎。谢谢大家的到来。
You guys aren't really fans. You're friends of ours. So that's very nice of you to show up. Thank you, everybody. Drive all the way out here to Long Island. Pay nothing. Really nice. Pay nothing.
你们其实不是粉丝，而是我们的朋友。所以你们能来真是太好了。谢谢大家。一路开车来到长岛。没花一分钱。真好。没花一分钱。
Right? Sit here and be like, all right. Entertain us. We're very excited to be doing like, so we're going to do four live shows. Every year. Every year. You know, we're going to do the... We're open to less, Scott, but that's fine.
对吧？坐在这里说，好吧，娱乐我们吧。我们非常兴奋能做这样的节目，所以我们打算每年做四场现场演出。每年。每年。你知道，我们打算做……斯科特，我们对少做几场也持开放态度，但这样也挺好。
We do the regular sort of podcast on the computer thing, right? What do you watch it here, listen to it on, whatever it is. And then we're going to do four live shows. This is our first one. Very excited about it. On top of that, we've got our white whale. People would ask me, like, who have you not interviewed that you want to? Howard Stern?
我们平时在电脑上做那种常规的播客，对吧？无论你在哪里看，或者在哪里听，随便什么地方。然后我们打算做四场现场演出。这是第一场。对此感到非常兴奋。除此之外，我们还有我们的“白鲸”。人们常问我，你还没采访过谁，但你想采访谁？霍华德·斯特恩？
Because he doesn't do this, and he's the man. He is the man. No, we feel very, very blessed that he, and we'll give him that in a second. Is that your intro? I don't have an intro. Sean's got an intro. Look at the cards. I wrote a bunch of stuff for a week.
因为他不干这种事，而且他是大人物。他就是那个大人物。不，我们感到非常、非常幸运，他能来，我们一会儿就会介绍他。那是你的开场白吗？我没有开场白。肖恩有开场白。看看那些卡片。我花了一周时间写了一堆东西。
I do want to say something. I'm like fanning. who's the little Dakota fanning when she was a little girl? She was really over-prepared and the best way I did cat in the hat with her. Go on. We got something to trim already. The audience is riveted by that story.
我确实想说点什么。我像个小迷弟一样。那个小达科塔·范宁，她小时候是谁？她当时准备得太充分了，我跟她一起拍《戴帽子的猫》时，我做得最好的方式就是……继续吧。我们已经有东西要剪掉了。观众对那个故事听得入迷了。
Fucking what? Dakota Fanning? Well, she's really smart and like prepared. I love that. But everybody here knows who our guest's going to be, so there are not a lot of surprises. So there is one surprise that we do have today just to kind of get the
去他的什么？达科塔·范宁？好吧，她真的很聪明，而且准备得很充分。我喜欢那样。但这里的每个人都知道我们的嘉宾会是谁，所以没什么太大的惊喜。不过今天确实有一个惊喜，只是为了让……
everybody warmed up to get us warmed up a little bit something Sean you don't know about uh oh yeah don't wait it's not your dad we still can't find him it's so fun because he left top speed you know he came
让大家热热身，让我们也热热身，有些肖恩不知道的事情。哦，对了，别等了，不是你爸爸，我们还是找不到他。这太有趣了，因为他以最高速度离开了，你知道他来了……
tears are still wet but I would tell you he came to the last show of Goodnight Oscar in Chicago yeah what you want us through that this is kind of a sad story I don't know if this we want to Yeah. But anyway, we can get back to that again. Keep going. That's a true story. He did. He came to the last show. I didn't even know he was there. Did he go backstage? No. No. It was wild. Go ahead.
眼泪还没干，但我得告诉你，他来了芝加哥《晚安，奥斯卡》的最后一场演出。是的，你想让我们讲讲这个吗？这算是个悲伤的故事，我不知道我们是否想……是的。但不管怎样，我们可以再回到那个话题。继续。那是真实的故事。他确实来了。他来了最后一场演出。我甚至不知道他在那儿。他去后台了吗？没有。没有。太疯狂了。继续吧。
Did he have notes? Yes. Yes, he emailed them to me. That is pretty weird. Wait, did you see him? I didn't. My sister, he... Tracy? Yes. My... That's correct. He emailed my... I'm sorry, he posted on Facebook that he went to the last show, and that's all he wrote. and my sister, to bait him like,
他有笔记吗？有。有，他发邮件给我了。那真是太奇怪了。等等，你见到他了吗？我没见到。我姐姐，他……特蕾西？是的。我……没错。他给我姐姐发了……抱歉，他在Facebook上发帖说他去了最后一场演出，他只写了这些。我姐姐为了引诱他，就说……
don't you want to say something about your son that you haven't seen in 75 years? He said... You look great. You look great. Yeah. And he just wrote back, Oscar Levant, just like I remembered him, that was it.
你难道不想对你75年没见的儿子说点什么吗？他说……你看上去很棒。你看上去很棒。是的。他只是回了一句，奥斯卡·黎凡特，就像我记忆中的他一样，就这样。
Isn't that, wow? Anyway. How long have you not seen him? 40 years. And he's in the theater with you. You just started in something. He didn't stick around to say, no.
那不是，哇？不管怎样。你有多久没见他了？40年。而他就在剧院里和你在一起。你刚开始演什么东西。他没留下来打招呼，没有。
What a treat. And then, wait. And then, and then, check this out. Two gay guys. came up to Scotty in the audience because Scotty was there and they go, are you Scotty? That's not the whole story? Okay.
真是难得。然后，等等。然后，然后，看看这个。两个同性恋家伙在观众席里走到斯科蒂面前，因为斯科蒂在那儿，他们说，你是斯科蒂吗？那不是故事的全部？好吧。
They came up to Scotty and they said, they said, oh, I just want to let you know we live next door to Sean's dad and I understand they don't see eye to eye. Was that a shot at your mom? For those of you who don't know, Sean's mom famously has one fake eye. Yes, hat, hat, hat, hat.
他们走到斯科蒂面前说，他们说，哦，我只是想让你知道，我们住在肖恩爸爸隔壁，我听说他们关系不太好。那是针对你妈妈的吗？对于那些不知道的人，肖恩的妈妈有一只假眼是很有名的。是的，帽子，帽子，帽子，帽子。
Because hilariously she died. So Sean should be an axe murderer, right? I mean, but he's... Let's see how this goes. He's the nicest guy. He's the kindest, and we love him. Oh, we all have, we all have skeletons. Go ahead.
因为滑稽的是她去世了。所以肖恩应该是个杀人狂，对吧？我是说，但他……让我们看看这会怎么发展。他是最棒的人。他是最善良的，我们爱他。哦，我们都有，我们都有不可告人的秘密。继续吧。
We love one-eyed parents. So we do have one surprise tonight, just so, you know, just trying to bring us out of the whole of Sean's upbringing. So I've asked the guy to come here tonight just to do a little something before we get going. Are you serious? I'm serious. I'm sorry.
我们爱独眼的父母。所以我们今晚确实有一个惊喜，只是，你知道，试图把我们从肖恩的成长经历中拉出来。所以我请了这位先生今晚来这里，在我们开始之前做点小表演。你是认真的吗？我是认真的。抱歉。
Yeah, he's an Emmy winner. He's a finalist on a... He's a finalist on America's Got Talent. He's been on the Jimmy Fallon program, amongst others. Is that what it's called the program? It's called the Jimmy Fallon program. That's what the producers tell me. I don't know.
是的，他是艾美奖得主。他是《美国达人秀》的决赛选手。他上过吉米·法伦的节目，还有其他节目。那个节目叫这个名字吗？叫吉米·法伦节目。制片人是这么告诉我的。我不知道。
There he is, Jimmy. Thank you, Jimmy. Please don't stand up. No, please don't sit down. Mr. Fallon. I beg you to sit down. Thank you to sit down. Fucking.
他就在那儿，吉米。谢谢你，吉米。请别站起来。不，请别坐下。法伦先生。我求你坐下。谢谢你坐下。该死的。
Love it. God, we saw the Olympics. It wasn't an intro, Jimmy. We get it. You're on NBC. Yeah. And you own one. Wayfarers.
喜欢这个。天哪，我们看了奥运会。那不是开场白，吉米。我们明白了。你在NBC工作。是的。而且你有一副Wayfarer眼镜。
By the way, Jimmy, on all serious, is you were great in Jurassic World. I thought that was great. Down again. Again, down. But he is, he's done so many things. No, he's a big...
顺便说一句，吉米，说正经的，你在《侏罗纪世界》里演得真棒。我觉得那很棒。又下来了。再一次，下来。但他确实，他做了很多事情。不，他是个大……
No, she's not here, man. She didn't make it. She's working on her stuff. He's one of the world's most sought-after mentalists. He's originally clients raging from A-less celebrities, heads estate, Fortune 500 companies, Guys, please welcome the amazing O's Perlman.
不，她不在这里，伙计。她没能来。她正在忙她的事情。他是世界上最受欢迎的读心师之一。他最初的客户范围从A级名流、国家元首到财富500强公司。伙计们，请欢迎神奇的奥斯·珀尔曼。
Just to pick us off. Guys, do a little something special for us. What? I didn't know. Not the coat of fanning, unfortunately. I know. Wait, as a surprise to Sean. He was waiting for me to be his dad.
就从这里开始吧。伙计们，为我们做点特别的事情。什么？我不知道。可惜不是达科塔·范宁。我知道。等等，这是给肖恩的惊喜。他一直在等我成为他爸爸。
I'm sorry, Sean. Wait, can I tell you something? Tell me. He sends me clips of you all the time. That's what Will told me. I'm obsessed. I think this is amazing. Sean legit doesn't know anything about this.
抱歉，肖恩。等等，我能告诉你一件事吗？告诉我。他一直给我发你的视频片段。威尔就是这么告诉我的。我着迷了。我觉得这太神奇了。肖恩真的对此一无所知。
Sean has no idea. This is wild. Will, you have my phone number, right? Yeah. And my email address? Yeah, I got it all. I don't like clips of things. Do you know who this is?
肖恩完全不知道。这太疯狂了。威尔，你有我的电话号码，对吧？是的。还有我的电子邮件地址？是的，我都有。我不喜欢视频片段。你知道这是谁吗？
Do you know who this is? You're too grouchy. He sort of clued me into it. It's our smart list on Moose Bush today, right? Yeah, yeah. Wait, this is so cool. This is so cool. Supposedly I read minds, but if I'm going to know how people think.
你知道这是谁吗？你太暴躁了。他算是给我透了点底。这是我们今天的《Smartless》嘉宾，对吧？是的，是的。等等，这太酷了。这太酷了。据说我能读心，但如果我要知道人们在想什么。
Yeah. Right? And you know what they're thinking at the same time. This is... Here's Will's skill. Everybody, where are my smartless fans in the room? Come on. Will notoriously knows dates, years behind.
是的。对吧？而且你同时知道他们在想什么。这是……这是威尔的技能。大家，我的《Smartless》粉丝都在房间里吗？来吧。威尔以记得日期和年份而闻名。
Everything. You can tell them June 2006. He knows what he's wearing. Jason can't remember what he had for breakfast today. Am I right? That's right. Sean Webby Award winner, best host. I thought you're going to say, Sean, ate Jason's breakfast.
所有事情。你可以告诉他2006年6月。他知道他当时穿什么。杰森记不住他今天早餐吃了什么。我说得对吗？没错。肖恩，威比奖得主，最佳主持人。我以为你要说，肖恩吃了杰森的早餐。
That might have been. Here's what I want you to do. I'm putting tasks. Putting tasks out there. You're going back in time thinking of somebody that these guys would not know somebody from your past, that they would not. You know what? Jason, go back in time. Think of the first girl you ever had a big crush on.
那倒有可能。这是我想让你做的。我正在布置任务。布置任务。你要回到过去，想一个这些人不认识的人，一个你过去的人，他们不会知道的。你知道吗？杰森，回到过去。想想你第一个暗恋的女孩。
Think to how old you were at the time. I got it. And tell them, because if I'm listening to this on my podcast. podcast right now. I'm saying this is set up, this is fake. Before today and me asking you to think of her, has it been days, months, or years since this person popped in your mind? Years. Years.
想想你当时多大。我记住了。告诉他们，因为如果我现在在我的播客上听这个。播客现在。我会说这是安排好的，这是假的。在今天之前，在我让你想她之前，这个人出现在你脑海里已经过去几天、几个月还是几年了？几年。几年。
Yeah. They didn't even know it's going to be on the show. Count the number of letters in her first name just to yourself. No, don't use your fingers. Jason, I can see your fingers. Okay, you're yelling at me. I'm fucking nervous that you're going to guess it and I'm going to be all freaked out. This is coming
是的。他们甚至不知道这会出现在节目里。数数她名字里的字母数量，只在心里数。不，别用手指。杰森，我能看到你的手指。好吧，你在对我大喊大叫。我他妈很紧张，怕你猜出来，我会吓坏的。这就要……
out at your time, Howard. Five letters. Was it five letters? Yes. He has not thought of this person in years. This is not set up, because if it was, it'd be going better. Tell us all. For everybody listening, I have written down, everybody in the room, don't say the name, but if you can see what I wrote down, clear as day, everybody in the room say, yeah.
出来了，霍华德。五个字母。是五个字母吗？是的。他已经好几年没想过这个人了。这不是安排好的，因为如果是的话，效果会更好。告诉我们所有人。对于所有听众，我已经写下来了，房间里的每个人，别说出名字，但如果你能看到我写的东西，像白天一样清晰，房间里的每个人都说，耶。
Close your eyes for me, Jason, close your eyes. But if you get this, like, you're going to be in my life the rest of my life. That is what I do. I'm never going to let you go. Like a splinter that doesn't leave. Well, clearly you let her go, but go ahead. You haven't thought of in years. I wrote it down.
闭上眼睛，杰森，闭上眼睛。但如果你猜对了，就像，你余生都会出现在我的生活中。这就是我做的。我永远不会让你走。就像一根拔不掉的刺。好吧，显然你让她走了，但继续吧。你已经好几年没想过她了。我写下来了。
Everybody in the room has seen it. How old were you at the time, Jason? 14. Ooh, 14. And tell us, what was this young lady's name? Paula. Paula, 14. For those who can't see Jason's face, he is in shock.
房间里的每个人都看到了。你当时多大，杰森？14岁。噢，14岁。告诉我们，这位年轻女士的名字是什么？宝拉。宝拉，14岁。对于那些看不到杰森脸的人，他现在处于震惊中。
Yeah, like, but why aren't you a trillionaire on Wall Street? It's my former job. Will, you thought of something. You're wasting this at Stephen Talk House. I'm monetizing. We're in the Hamptons, Jason. trust me, I'm monetizing. Will, Will, you're back in time, you're thinking of somebody.
是的，就像，但你为什么不是华尔街的亿万富翁？那是我的前一份工作。威尔，你想到了一些事情。你在斯蒂芬·托克豪斯浪费这个。我在赚钱。我们在汉普顿，杰森。相信我，我在赚钱。威尔，威尔，你回到过去，你在想某个人。
Jason's shook up, by the way. I wish they could see his face and not just hear the text of his voice. That's the most surprised his face gets, by the way. You know, what do you think your face is doing right now? Smiling? It's very good. Sean, how about this? All right.
顺便说一句，杰森被吓到了。我希望他们能看到他的脸，而不只是听到他声音的文字。顺便说一句，这是他脸上最惊讶的表情。你知道，你觉得你现在的脸在做什么？微笑？这很好。肖恩，这个怎么样？好吧。
You read his mind. You were so confident with Jason, and then you had no idea. Is there any way in the world, Will, that Sean knows who popped to you? your head when I asked you to think of somebody from your past? No. Okay. Take a pad of paper.
你读了他的心。你对杰森那么自信，然后你却毫无头绪。威尔，世界上有没有可能肖恩知道当我让你想一个过去的人时，谁出现在你的脑海里？没有。好吧。拿个记事本。
Yep. Sean, here's the game plan. Okay, I'm so scared. I need you to act. Good luck. Sean, look at my hands. And can you tell everybody listening in, I'm going to pretend in a moment I have a crystal ball in my hand.
是的。肖恩，这是游戏计划。好吧，我太害怕了。我需要你表演。祝你好运。肖恩，看我的手。你能告诉所有听众，我一会儿要假装我手里有一个水晶球吗？
Do I actually have anything in my hands? Zero, nothing. Everyone in the audience. Is there anything my hands? No. Sean will swear up and down that he saw a crystal ball appear in my hands and in it the name of your friend as a kid, or whoever this person is.
我手里真的有什么东西吗？零，什么都没有。观众席里的每个人。我手里有什么东西吗？没有。肖恩会发誓说他看到一个水晶球出现在我手里，里面有你小时候朋友的名字，或者不管这人是谁。
Have you written down a name? I have. Can anybody see it right now other than you? I don't think so. Sean, look into Will's soul. And tell him... Good luck. What name did you see in that crystal ball?
你写下名字了吗？写了。除了你之外，现在有人能看到它吗？我想没有。肖恩，看着威尔的灵魂。告诉他……祝你好运。你在那个水晶球里看到了什么名字？
Tell him what... Before I walked in here, we spoke in a word in our life, Sean. Never. Tell him who's he thinking of. Say it. Scott. You fucking...
告诉他什么……在我走进这里之前，我们这辈子说过话吗，肖恩。从来没有。告诉他他在想谁。说出来。斯科特。你他妈的……
What? Turn around, show the audience. Fucking what? I can't hear you in this room. Are you seeing the same show? How is that possible? How is that possible? Holy shit, that is unbelievable.
什么？转过身，给观众看。去他的什么？在这个房间里我听不见你说话。你们看到的是同一个节目吗？这怎么可能？这怎么可能？天哪，这太不可思议了。
Thank you very much for having me, guys. Huge fan. Huge fan. Incredible. So, guys, how do you introduce a man who needs no introduction because he's one of the most famous people in the planet, plus he's on the poster outside? He's the king of all media, the interviewer of all interviewers,
非常感谢你们邀请我，伙计们。超级粉丝。超级粉丝。不可思议。那么，伙计们，你们怎么介绍一个不需要介绍的人，因为他是这个星球上最著名的人之一，而且他还在外面的海报上？他是所有媒体之王，采访者中的采访者，
the winner of Best Hair in America, four years in a row. He's a great artist, a great painting. More sincere. Yeah, no, I lost my thing. And he is incredible. He's the most amazing person.
连续四年美国最佳发型得主。他是一位伟大的艺术家，一幅伟大的画作。更真诚。是的，不，我丢了我的东西。而且他不可思议。他是最了不起的人。
And now his home for 20 years has been serious X-M, which is now ours, which makes us roomies. It's the most incredible icon of all time, Howard Stern. Ever. Yes. All my years in radio. Yes. Nothing works better on radio than magic. Yeah, sure.
现在他20年的家是天狼星XM，现在也是我们的家，这让我们成了室友。这是有史以来最不可思议的偶像，霍华德·斯特恩。有史以来。是的。我做广播的所有岁月。是的。在广播里，没有什么比魔术效果更好的了。是的，当然。
You guys are on to something. It's a great note. I told you, Arnett. I don't want to come off like an expert. I've only been doing this for like 50 years. You've also made Howard the second guest. When's the last time you weren't the lead guest? I know, and I remember having amazing Kreskin on,
你们搞出名堂了。这是一个很棒的笔记。我告诉过你，阿内特。我不想表现得像个专家。我只做了大约50年。你们也让霍华德成了第二个嘉宾。你上次不是首席嘉宾是什么时候？我知道，我记得请过伟大的克雷斯金，
and the audience was amazed as I described everything that was going on in the room. The play-by-play was unbelievable. Yeah. He made a table lift, and I go, if you were here now, you'd see a table lifting off the ground. And people are like, no wonder this is such a great radio. First of all, welcome to Sirius XM, the glorious world of Sirius XM. I'm a huge fan of the company, so welcome.
观众很惊讶，因为我描述了房间里发生的一切。现场直播真是不可思议。是的。他让桌子升起来了，我说，如果你现在在这里，你会看到一张桌子从地上升起来。人们说，难怪这是这么棒的广播。首先，欢迎来到天狼星XM，天狼星XM的光辉世界。我是这家公司的超级粉丝，所以欢迎。
You know, I don't even know how long I've been with Sirius XM. Since it started, you started it. When I started, we had 200,000 subscribers. And I remember walking around in, I don't even know where I was, somewhere in Manhattan, handing out radios for free, hoping that someone would take one. Yeah. And it was a harrowing experience leaving Terrestrial Radio and coming to series,
你知道，我甚至不知道我在天狼星XM待了多久。从它开始，你就开始了。我开始的时候，我们有20万订阅者。我记得我走在，我甚至不知道我在哪里，在曼哈顿的某个地方，免费分发收音机，希望有人能拿一个。是的。离开地面广播来到天狼星是一次痛苦的经历，
but it was the best decision I ever made. And you weren't allowed to talk about it, too, right? When you were at the very end there, when you're on Terrestrial Radio, I remember that. Yeah, it was a very strange time in my career. I was on regular radio, and I somehow convinced them that it would be okay if I talked about the fact that I was leaving regular radio and going to satellite radio. And then they told me okay. They said, don't mention serious radio.
但这是我做过的最好的决定。而且你当时还不被允许谈论它，对吧？当你在最后的时候，当你在地面广播时，我记得那个。是的，那是我职业生涯中非常奇怪的时期。我在常规广播电台工作，我不知怎么说服了他们，如果我谈论我即将离开常规广播去卫星广播的事实，那会没事的。然后他们告诉我好吧。他们说，别提天狼星广播。
Just call it something else. So we called it, eh, eh, eh, eh, eh, and, and, and, and, uh. And, uh, what you did for it, though, because we had all sort of heard that satellite radio was coming, and I was a little circumspect. And I was, which one are you? You're Jason. I'm Jason. That's Jason. And I was like, well, I don't know if I want, like, satellite, I got to get a different radio for that.
随便叫它别的什么。所以我们叫它，呃，呃，呃，呃，呃，还有，还有，还有，还有，呃。而且，呃，你为它所做的，因为我们都听说卫星广播要来了，我有点谨慎。你是哪一个？你是杰森。我是杰森。那是杰森。我当时想，好吧，我不知道我是否想要，像，卫星，我得为此买个不同的收音机。
When you went to satellite, I was like, oh, it's okay now. I'm going to go to it. It was like when Fincher went to Netflix, it was like, oh. You do forget because things move rather rapidly, but it was a very strange time because there was an effort by regular radio to say, what a failure I would be. Right. And they were putting out that anyone who went to satellite radio,
当你去卫星广播时，我当时想，哦，现在没问题了。我要去用它。就像芬奇去Netflix时，就像，哦。你确实会忘记，因为事情发展得相当快，但那是一个非常奇怪的时期，因为常规广播电台试图说，我会是一个多么大的失败者。对。他们散布说，任何去卫星广播的人，
your career would be over, you would disappear forever. And, you know, so there was this big campaign to, you know, discredit satellite radio. Yeah. But I knew deep in my heart that satellite radio would be successful. And now I look around, everybody's got a fucking microphone in their house. Everybody's on the radio. You three. You want to hear the most aggravating things.
你的职业生涯就会结束，你会永远消失。而且，你知道，所以有一场大运动来，你知道，抹黑卫星广播。是的。但我内心深处知道卫星广播会成功。现在我环顾四周，每个人的家里都有一个该死的麦克风。每个人都在广播。你们三个。你想听听最令人恼火的事情吗？
But Howard, I do love you guys. But. Yeah. A couple things. Jason and I, the only person I didn't know was Sean. Right. It's nice to meet you. Nice to meet you.
但是霍华德，我确实爱你们。但是。是的。几件事。杰森和我，我唯一不认识的人是肖恩。对。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。
And I do want to ask you about your classical piano. All right. And I want to ask you about your guitar playing. Yes, I'm most impressed with your classical piano. Well, you guys will get some time after the interview. No, but here's the thing I want to tell you that annoying. Can I tell you this? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我确实想问你关于你的古典钢琴。好吧。我还想问你关于你的吉他演奏。是的，我对你的古典钢琴印象最深。好吧，采访结束后你们会有一些时间。不，但这是我想告诉你的，很烦人。我能告诉你这个吗？是的，是的，是的。
So Jason was over my house, and I have mad respect for Jason. I think you're a fabulous actor. Incredible, one of the best. Wonderful guy. He's overcome a million people. You know the problems? You know the problems? You know the problems.
所以杰森在我家，我对杰森有极大的尊重。我觉得你是一位出色的演员。不可思议，最棒的之一。很棒的家伙。他克服了百万人。你知道那些问题吗？你知道那些问题吗？你知道那些问题。
A lot of fucking problems. A lot of. And he still has a bunch. Yeah, he's got a lot of problems. Look at him. We could go on all day. But, you know, I'm talking to Jason, and I'm feeling very good about my own career and everything.
很多该死的问题。很多。而且他还有一堆。是的，他有很多问题。看看他。我们可以整天谈论这个。但是，你知道，我在和杰森谈话，我对自己职业生涯的一切感觉很好。
And Jason goes, you know, man, it's crazy. We like started this thing out of our basement, like a radio show. And I'm like, oh, here we go. Yeah, cool. And he goes, yeah, we started a thing. And like, it was just the three of us sitting around and we talk and we just crack each other up and everything. I don't know what's going to happen with it, man. But they're telling me it's like the biggest thing ever.
杰森说，你知道，伙计，这太疯狂了。我们就像从地下室开始做这个东西，就像一个广播节目。我当时想，哦，开始了。是的，酷。他说，是的，我们开始了一个东西。就像我们三个人坐在一起，我们聊天，我们只是互相逗乐等等。我不知道这会发生什么，伙计。但他们告诉我这就像有史以来最大的东西。
Oh, shit. I didn't say that. Oh, yeah. No way. Oh, yeah, you did. So I go, oh, this is great. Again, I spent my life. Yes.
哦，该死。我没那么说。哦，是的。不可能。哦，是的，你说了。所以我说，哦，这太棒了。再一次，我花了我的一生。是的。
Like begging people to put me on the radio. It was rarefied air if you even were allowed on the air. Had to work on your voice, this and that. You had to work on the content. You had to make sure you get people. He's clowning around. So, listen, it's over. What can I say?
乞求人们让我上广播。如果你能上广播，那简直是稀有的空气。必须在你的声音上下功夫，这个那个。你必须在内容上下功夫。你必须确保你吸引人们。他在胡闹。所以，听着，结束了。我能说什么？
I know, but you talk about... You hide your... You hide your bitterness really well. Oh, I'm so better. So better. You talk about perfecting your craft. So how did you first meet the whack pack? Oh, that's an excellent question.
我知道，但你谈论……你隐藏你的……你隐藏你的痛苦隐藏得很好。哦，我很痛苦。很痛苦。你谈论完善你的手艺。那么你是怎么第一次见到“怪胎帮”的？哦，那是个极好的问题。
It is. I want to know, because you did. You found, like, the craziest group of people. available and put them together? How did that come together? The whack... Listen, when I was on the radio, and it was brutal,
确实。我想知道，因为你确实做到了。你找到了，像，最疯狂的一群人。可用的，并把他们放在一起？那是怎么凑到一起的？怪胎……听着，当我在广播里时，那很残酷，
in order to get an audience and to maintain an audience, every 15 minutes, they take the ratings in radio. It isn't like this, like where you go, you know, we have a lot of people listening. You know, it could be three people listening to this. Nobody knows, nobody cares. But you're on the radio,
为了获得听众并维持听众，广播里每15分钟就会进行一次收视率调查。不像这样，像你说的，你知道，我们有很多听众。你知道，可能只有三个人在听这个。没人知道，没人关心。但你在广播里，
and every 15 minutes, they take ratings. And what do you? going to do to hold people's attention? But you found all these people like this kind of... But look, I found people that I was interested in. I'll never forget the day. I was on the radio and I took
每15分钟，他们就会进行收视率调查。你打算做什么来吸引人们的注意力？但你找到了所有这些人，像这种……但看，我找到了我感兴趣的人。我永远不会忘记那一天。我在广播里，我去了
a little bathroom break and I walked by my green room. The lights went up. I'm looking at the room and there he is. Beetle juice. Beetle juice. You know my... Jason, you ever hear my show?
个洗手间休息，我走过我的休息室。灯亮了。我看着房间，他就在那儿。甲壳虫汁。甲壳虫汁。你知道我的……杰森，你听过我的节目吗？
In high school, I listened to it a lot. There was a guy named Beetlejuice who's very popular, even to this day on the internet. It's insanely popular. Right, right. So, you know, I said, this guy's a star. He's going to be fantastic. Yeah, be quiet, so they don't hear, right? This guy's going to be a star.
在高中时，我听了很多。有一个叫甲壳虫汁的人，他非常受欢迎，即使在今天在互联网上。它非常受欢迎。对，对。所以，你知道，我说，这家伙是个明星。他会很棒的。是的，安静点，这样他们就听不见了，对吧？这家伙会成为明星。
This guy's going to be a star. And sure enough, he was. No, I mean, I was always looking for interesting people. I have a question about that. Early on, where did you get the balls to not give a shit about the consequences? of what you were saying and what you were doing on air. Where do you get that from?
这家伙会成为明星。果然，他是。不，我是说，我一直在寻找有趣的人。我对此有个问题。早期，你从哪里得到胆量不去管后果？你所说的和你所做的事情在广播里。你从哪里得到那个？
Because do you think you would have that now if you start your career now with the same personality since we live in cancel culture? Go ahead. I believe I was technically insane. I mean, I don't, I can't even... Like, you had like this level of a difference?
因为你认为如果你现在开始你的职业生涯，带着同样的个性，既然我们生活在取消文化中，你还会有那个吗？继续吧。我相信我当时在技术上是疯了。我是说，我甚至不能……就像你当时有这种程度的差异？
No, not self-sabotage. Well, here's the truth. In my family, words meant nothing. My mother would say actions only mean anything. And I guess I told you. or literally. Howard, what would you consider
不，不是自我破坏。好吧，事实是。在我的家庭里，言语毫无意义。我母亲会说只有行动才有意义。我想我告诉过你。或者字面上。霍华德，你认为什么
would be the sort of the turning point in your career where you kind of broke through because, again,
会是你职业生涯的转折点，你算是突破了，因为，再一次，
you started, you had all these, you sort of, you keyed into this kind of thing with odd characters on your show, but what was the turning point
你开始了，你有了所有这些，你算是锁定了这种东西，在你的节目里有奇怪的角色，但转折点是什么
where you felt like you broke through to a bigger audience? I had a miserable failure in Detroit. I got hired to be the morning man at WWW
你觉得你突破到了更大的受众？我在底特律遭遇了惨败。我被雇为WWW的早间主持人
WW in Detroit. Which are the First call letters for a radio station. I get on there and go, WWW, Detroit, W, W, W, W, W, I don't know what I'm doing. So I was hired to be the morning man. I had had some success in Hartford,
WW在底特律。这是广播电台的第一个呼号。我上去说，WWW，底特律，W，W，W，W，W，我不知道我在做什么。所以我被雇为早间主持人。我在哈特福德取得了一些成功，
not a huge success, but success. And I got hired in Detroit. And there was a radio consultant who said to me, do not go to Detroit. There are four rock stations. And out of the four, the one that they want to hire you at, dead last. Nobody even, I would go to parties,
不是巨大的成功，但成功。我在底特律被雇用了。有一位广播顾问对我说，不要去底特律。那里有四个摇滚电台。在四个中，他们想雇你的那个，排在最后。没人，我会去参加聚会，
and people would say, do for a living. I'd say, oh, I'm the morning guy in W4. They go, oh, is that station still on the air? Nobody listened to this thing. W4 was a short version of WWW. W. Detroit's W4, the worst station. So, yeah, I went on the radio in Detroit. It was a tremendous failure, and I said, what am I doing wrong? And I sat with it and I thought, I've got to really just, I guess, lose all inhibition and admit to everything and just see where that goes. And when I went to Washington, D.C. bucket. It was like it was not going
人们会说，做什么谋生。我说，哦，我是W4的早间主持人。他们说，哦，那个电台还在广播吗？没人听这个东西。W4是WWW的缩写版本。W。底特律的W4，最差的电台。所以，是的，我在底特律上了广播。那是一次巨大的失败，我说，我做错了什么？我坐在那里想，我想我真的必须，我想，失去所有的抑制，承认一切，看看会发生什么。当我去了华盛顿特区时，该死。就像它没有进展
great and he was like might as well throw it all against the wall. But I have to give the credit to also Robin Quivers. I met her in Washington and she was phenomenal. The chemistry was great and a program director put us together and I went on the air with her and I started to become very
很好，他就像不妨把一切都扔到墙上。但我必须把功劳也归于罗宾·奎弗斯。我在华盛顿遇见了她，她非常出色。化学反应很好，节目总监把我们放在一起，我和她一起上了广播，我开始变得非常
confessional and people respond. We shot up to number one in a record amount of time. Because it was real and honest and so that was the moment when you started getting really real about your own life that started to change it. Yes. And did you did you notice being real about your life? Because so much, you know,
忏悔，人们回应了。我们在创纪录的时间内飙升至第一名。因为它是真实和诚实的，所以那是你开始真正谈论你自己的生活，开始改变它的时候。是的。你有没有注意到谈论你的生活？因为很多，你知道，
anybody who's listening to the show, knows that you talk about what's going on in your life, what you did on the weekend, new haircut, new clothes, whatever. Wait a second. I was masturbating at least three times a day and talking about it. I was trying to, like, my kids are here, so. I'm not sorry.
任何听节目的人都知道，你谈论你生活中发生的事情，你周末做了什么，新发型，新衣服，随便什么。等等。我每天至少自慰三次，并且谈论它。我试图，像，我的孩子们在这里，所以。我不抱歉。
And I'm not sure there's been a new haircut. How many do you have exactly? I mean, we're looking into it. But the point is... We've got to find out. The point is, is... You talked about... You talked about...
而且我不确定有没有新发型。你到底有多少个？我是说，我们正在调查。但重点是……我们得查清楚。重点是，是……你谈论了……你谈论了……
You talked about so much about your personal life. Was there a point we're talking about your personal life hurt your relationship? I don't mean necessarily even romantic. I mean, hurt relationships because people were nervous about talking to you at a party. Well, it hurt everything. It hurt my, but I didn't care. All I cared about was my job, keeping that job, and getting audience and ratings. And that is a disaster.
你谈论了这么多关于你的个人生活。有没有一个点谈论你的个人生活伤害了你的关系？我不一定是指浪漫关系。我是指，伤害了关系，因为人们在聚会上和你说话时很紧张。好吧，它伤害了一切。它伤害了我的，但我不在乎。我只关心我的工作，保住那份工作，获得受众和收视率。那是一场灾难。
But you wave at somebody on the street and go like, hey, and they're like, fuck man, I don't want to say hi to him because it's going to I'm going to end up on the show tomorrow. I mean, people thought, not only that, I went through a very strange period in time. I don't want to get all heavy about this because everyone knows the show is not heavy. No, no. I don't want to get happy.
但你在街上向某人挥手说，嘿，他们就像，去你的伙计，我不想和他打招呼，因为这会……我明天会出现在节目里。我是说，人们认为，不仅如此，我经历了一个非常奇怪的时期。我不想对此变得沉重，因为每个人都知道节目不沉重。不，不。我不想变得快乐。
We're going to make you cry before you're out of here. Okay, well, I'll do that. What it was is that I was very insecure about my career. I wanted this thing to take off in the worst way. And so I even had a policy about I stayed in my home after I did my show
在你离开这里之前，我们会让你哭的。好吧，我会那样做的。事实是，我对我的职业生涯非常不安全。我非常想让这个东西起飞。所以我甚至有一个政策，我在做完节目后就待在家里
I never went out I was insane so I didn't want to meet anyone in show business because I didn't because I was talking on the air about a lot of people and I didn't want so I just stayed in my house I planned the radio show did it and went home and and the stuff I was doing was so outrageous
我从不出去，我疯了，所以我不想在演艺圈见任何人，因为我不想，因为我在广播里谈论很多人，我不想，所以我只是待在家里，我计划广播节目，做了它，然后回家，而且我做的事情太离谱了
and so entertaining to the audience that it blew up I mean in New York we had 25 million listeners and one out of every four cars on the Long Island Expresso he was listening to me. Wow. And it was pretty phenomenal. But I had no life.
对听众来说太有趣了，以至于它爆炸了。我是说，在纽约我们有2500万听众，长岛高速公路上每四辆车里就有一辆在听我。哇。这真是太惊人了。但我没有生活。
Don't applaud. I had no life. Where's Bradley Cooper? He's so good looking. But Howard, that shifted. If I looked like that, I wouldn't have to go on the radio and say shit. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
别鼓掌。我没有生活。布莱德利·库珀在哪里？他长得真好看。但是霍华德，那变了。如果我长那样，我就不必去广播里说废话了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
Howard, that shifted, though, because, and it was about, I'm going to say almost 10 years ago, maybe a little bit more, where you start. and you started hanging out with a lot of people, and your life changed, you heard. And you became kind of one of the people that used to talk in a certain way, right? Not one of the people, but you became friends with a lot of people.
霍华德，那变了，因为，大约是10年前，也许稍微多一点，你开始。你开始和很多人一起玩，你的生活变了，你听到了。你变得有点像你过去以某种方式谈论的人，对吧？不是其中之一，但你和很多人成了朋友。
I did. And you allowed celebrities into your life. You became friends with people like Jason Bateman from TV and film, who we all love. Well, my dream was to be friends with Jason Baton. Sure. There's only one way I'm going to get this. It's our dream, too.
我确实。而且你允许名流进入你的生活。你和像杰森·贝特曼这样我们都喜欢的电视和电影明星成了朋友。好吧，我的梦想是和杰森·贝特曼成为朋友。当然。我只有一种方法能得到这个。这也是我们的梦想。
But it shifted. Like, I remember back in the, I mean, years ago, you remember you used to call it Chevy Chase's household. the time. She used to drive him crazy. I told you I was insane. I know. But then it changes it because you have to meet those people right? Out of
但它变了。就像，我记得在，我是说，几年前，你记得你过去常称它为切维·切斯的家庭。那个时候。她过去常让他发疯。我告诉过你我疯了。我知道。但后来它变了，因为你必须见到那些人，对吧？走出
the world. Well, Chevy ended up coming to my wedding which is even more important. And got up to make a beautiful speech to myself and my bride and then stated to the audience that I had given him herpes in a moment. Wow. Which was really weird.
世界。好吧，切维最终来到了我的婚礼，这更重要。并站起来为我和我的新娘发表了美丽的演讲，然后向观众声明我在那一刻传染给他疱疹。哇。这真的很奇怪。
But I loved it. But your audience is bigger today than it's ever been and you're not doing all of those sort of shocking things. You're doing you're doing measured deep conversations long form interviews with very sophisticated people and
但我喜欢它。但你的受众今天比以往任何时候都大，而且你没有做所有那些令人震惊的事情。你正在做，你正在做有分量的深度对话，与非常老练的人进行长篇采访，而且
like so. Well because I think any good performer and you guys are great performers and you know this. You must evolve. The show you know I used to say this now Rush Limbaugh, forget the politics you know he had a very big following but it was the same thing
像这样。好吧，因为我认为任何好的表演者，你们都是伟大的表演者，你们知道这一点。你必须进化。节目，你知道，我过去常说这个，现在拉什·林博，忘了政治，你知道他有很多追随者，但那是同一件事
every day. You could predict what he was going to say. Some people like that because it's like comfort and whatever. They're comfort to them. But for me, as a performer, I felt I want the show to be funny. I also want to be able to interview people. I want it to be broader. And I made a conscious
每一天。你可以预测他会说什么。有些人喜欢那样，因为那就像安慰等等。他们对他们来说是安慰。但对我来说，作为表演者，我觉得我希望节目有趣。我也希望能够采访人们。我希望它更广泛。我做了一个有意识的
decision to shift the show and change it around. And to me, it was way more exciting because the common thought was, well, Howard will go to satellite, and now the show's going to be so fucking filthy, and everyone's going to be out of their mind, and it's going to, and the strippers are going to be able to fuck on the air.
决定去转换节目并改变它。对我来说，这比以往任何时候都更令人兴奋，因为普遍的想法是，好吧，霍华德会去卫星广播，现在节目会变得如此该死的肮脏，每个人都会失去理智，它会，而且脱衣舞娘将能够在广播里做爱。
Did you miss those constraints? No, no, the constraints, by having the constraints off, I said, well, then it's no longer funny. Exactly. Regular radio was funny. The government was trying to shut me down. That was drama. And that's fun.
你怀念那些限制吗？不，不，限制，通过取消限制，我说，好吧，那它就不再有趣了。正是。常规广播很有趣。政府试图关闭我。那是戏剧。那很有趣。
That's tension, right? But then I got to satellite. The tension wasn't there. So what do you do now that you have the ultimate freedom? Right. And I decided to shift the show. And I ultimately am more interested in the show now than I've ever been. I would say that it would, in a compliment to you, that it was,
那是紧张，对吧？但后来我去了卫星广播。紧张感不在了。所以现在你拥有终极自由，你做什么？对。我决定转换节目。我最终现在对节目比以往任何时候都更感兴趣。我会说，作为对你的赞美，它是，
less deliberate or contrived or strategic for you to, oh, let's switch it up now and give the audience something they're not going to expect. I think it's, and I haven't known you for, you know, a thousand years, but it does seem pretty obvious that you have naturally just evolved into a more curious, serious, not as a pejorative person who's interested in different kinds of questions and with different kinds of people. Let's make it simpler. Let's make it simpler. You know, it wasn't It would be really creepy to be my age and still doing a show the way I did it when I was 30. When I was 30, I was a hard. You were doing it as a ratings ploy.
对你来说不那么刻意、做作或有策略，哦，现在让我们转换一下，给观众一些他们意想不到的东西。我认为它是，而且我没有认识你，你知道，一千年，但看起来很明显，你自然而然地进化成了一个更好奇、更严肃的人，不是作为贬义词，而是对不同类型的问题和不同类型的人感兴趣的人。让我们简单点。让我们简单点。你知道，它不是，如果我这个年纪还像我30岁时那样做节目，那会非常令人毛骨悚然。当我30岁时，我是一个硬汉。你是在把它当作收视率策略。
You were being sincere and genuine. I thought I was funny. Yeah. And I always had this idea that we could be really funny on the radio. That radio didn't have to be a bastardized medium. No, but I mean now. Now it was not a ratings point now. And you are hands down the best interviewer in all of media.
你当时是真诚和真实的。我觉得我很有趣。是的。而且我一直有这个想法，我们可以在广播里非常有趣。广播不必是一种堕落的媒介。不，但我是说现在。现在它不是收视率策略。而且你毫无疑问是所有媒体中最好的采访者。
Thank you. It's true. Without a doubt. Take the compliment, Howard. I'm taking the compliment. No matter what. My psychiatrist said you should be able to take a compliment. Yeah, yeah.
谢谢。这是真的。毫无疑问。接受赞美，霍华德。我正在接受赞美。无论如何。我的精神科医生说你应该能够接受赞美。是的，是的。
And this is what I'm doing. Yeah, like, not, not, not, not, doesn't matter whether it's comics or athletes or musicians or, or, or actors or whatever it is, you, you, you, you question them for us as us. I love that aspect of. And it's a layman's point of view. And it's, it's very curious. And you're listening.
这就是我正在做的。是的，像，不，不，不，不，不管它是漫画家、运动员、音乐家、或者演员或者随便什么，你，你，你，你代表我们质疑他们。我喜欢那个方面。而且这是一个外行人的观点。而且它，它非常好奇。而且你在听。
You don't have a, you know, a bunch of fucking cards with questions on it. You're engaged in a conversation. and it was a true inspiration for us. Sean is holding up all his cards. By the way, let's let Sean get a question. He wrote a thousand. I literally, I have pages of them because I don't know. Sean and I don't really know each other.
你没有，你知道，一堆该死的卡片上面有问题。你参与了一场对话。而且这对我们来说是一个真正的灵感。肖恩正举着他所有的卡片。顺便说一句，让肖恩问个问题。他写了一千个。我字面上，我有几页，因为我不知道。肖恩和我并不真正了解彼此。
That's why I wrote all this stuff down. And my research of you, because I am a big fan, I found all these things that we actually do have in common growing up. Issues with our dad. You don't like Italy, which you just went with Jimmy Kimmel. I didn't want to go either. We're going to get, I want to go. Wait, boy, wait.
这就是为什么我写下所有这些东西。而且我对你的研究，因为我是个大粉丝，我发现所有这些我们实际上共同拥有的东西，成长过程中。和我们爸爸的问题。你不喜欢意大利，你刚和吉米·坎摩尔一起去过。我也不想去。我们要去，我想去。等等，伙计，等等。
Wait, bullying. Like, as a kid, I don't want to go. I was bullied to, not for being Jewish, but for being gay. He's going to get to the question. Oddly, I was bullied for being gay, and I wasn't. Crazy. I got bullied for everything. Well, I said, I'm not gay.
等等，欺凌。像，小时候，我不想去。我被欺凌，不是因为是犹太人，而是因为是同性恋。他要问问题了。奇怪的是，我因为是同性恋被欺凌，但我不是。疯狂。我因为一切被欺凌。好吧，我说，我不是同性恋。
We're sorry to see you leave. Leave that side. You seem very gay. But the thing that I thought was fascinating, my mom had a glass eye, your dad had a glass eye, and neither one of us. Neither one of us was allowed to talk about it. Can I ask you a question? Can you wait one second? Is your mom still alive?
很遗憾看到你要离开。把那边放下。你看起来很同性恋。但我认为最迷人的一点是，我妈有一只义眼，你爸也有一只义眼，我们俩谁都不被允许谈论这件事。我能问你个问题吗？你能等一秒钟吗？你妈妈还活着吗？
Is your mom still alive? No, she's dead. Okay. My father died two years ago. I know. I'm sorry to that about that. But I want to ask you a question. Yes, he has it.
你妈妈还活着吗？不，她去世了。好吧。我父亲两年前去世了。我知道。对此我很抱歉。但我得问你个问题。是的，他有那只眼睛。
Forget these other two guys. I'm asking you, because you had a mother with a glass eye. Yeah. So my father had this glass eye. And I could go into that for three hours. Same. Same. There's so many things.
别管那两个家伙了。我是在问你，因为你也有个装义眼的母亲。是的。我父亲有那只义眼。我可以就这个话题聊上三个小时。我也是。我也是。有太多事情了。
It's so fucking heavy. It's so great. But it's also, it's also funny. But when he died, I was given a box of his stuff. Yes. And it, what do you mean? Oh. Yeah.
这真是太沉重了。太棒了。但它也很有趣。但他去世时，我收到了一盒他的遗物。是的。什么意思？哦。是的。
I told you, you shouldn't have an audience of this guy. By the way, the same. I open up the box. Yeah. Of course. It's my father's glass eyes. Wait a minute. The same thing.
我告诉过你，你不该让这家伙有观众。顺便说一句，一样。我打开盒子。是的。当然。是我父亲的义眼。等一下。一样的情况。
When my mom died, my sister passed it around and repackaged it. Each one of us, we open, oh, we got something from my sister. It's my mom's fucking eye. Here comes the question. Here comes the question. Yeah. So I go to my wife. I say, I got this eye.
我妈去世时，我姐姐把它传阅了一圈，又重新包装好。我们每个人打开时，哦，我们从姐姐那儿拿到了东西。是我妈那该死的眼睛。问题来了。问题来了。是的。所以我去找我妻子。我说，我拿到了这只眼睛。
The great Beth. Beth. My beautiful Beth. Beth Stern. Where is she, honey? Where is Beth? Oh, there she is. Oh, there she is.
伟大的贝丝。贝丝。我美丽的贝丝。贝丝·斯特恩。她在哪里，亲爱的？贝丝在哪儿？哦，她在那儿。哦，她在那儿。
Oh, I love. I love you so much. Nice to meet you. I've heard such great things. So, anyway, here's the thing. So I turn to my wife and I say to my wife, yeah. You know, I don't know.
哦，我爱。我太爱你了。很高兴见到你。我听过很多关于你的好话。总之，事情是这样的。我转向我妻子，对她说，是的。你知道，我不知道。
I go and I open it up. And my father's eye was such a taboo subject. My father never talked to me about anything. That's right. And one time I asked my mother, does dad have a glass? And she said, listen to me. You, that's your father's story. Don't ask me.
我去把它打开了。我父亲的眼睛是个禁忌话题。我父亲从不跟我谈论任何事。没错。有一次我问我母亲，爸爸有义眼吗？她说，听着。你，那是你父亲的故事。别问我。
And I'm like, what the fuck? I was like a kid. How old? Okay, here's the deal. How old were you and you still didn't know whether your dad's eye was glass? No, they wouldn't talk. And did it blink shut? Did it blink shut or did it stay open?
我当时想，搞什么鬼？我还是个孩子。多大？好吧，情况是这样的。你多大时还不知道你爸爸的眼睛是义眼？不，他们不谈论。它会眨眼吗？它会闭上还是保持睁开？
Did it blink shut or stay open? It stayed mostly open and also things would form. You needed to confirm? My mom are kind of shades like a sort of like a tinted glasses or something? It wasn't the confirmation of the glass. I wanted to know what happened with my father. That's right, yes. But I wasn't allowed to ask.
它会闭上还是保持睁开？它大部分时间是睁着的，而且还会形成一些东西。你需要确认吗？我妈那种像是有色眼镜之类的东西？那不是对义眼的确认。我想知道我父亲身上发生了什么。没错，是的。但我没被允许问。
My father would blow up if everyone was afraid. get really angry. You could throw that eye at you. You could. Yeah. But here's my question. So what? So now I have the eye and I said to my wife, I need to find that.
我父亲会大发雷霆，每个人都很害怕。变得非常生气。他可能会把那只眼睛扔向你。他真的会。是的。但这是我的问题。那又怎样？现在我有这只眼睛了，我对妻子说，我得处理掉它。
I can't just take my father's eye and throw it in the garbage. Like there might be laws against that. I don't know. Are there? I don't know. Wouldn't you want to save it as a keepsake? No. No, no, no.
我不能就这样把我父亲的眼睛扔进垃圾桶。好像法律禁止这样做。我不知道。有吗？我不知道。你难道不想把它留作纪念吗？不。不，不，不。
Beth, where is it? It's a cat toy now. She's got it in a locket around her night. She brought it here for you guys. No, it's a, so she says to me, throw it in the ocean. I go, I'm not going to throw my... I'm not...
贝丝，它在哪儿？现在是个猫玩具了。她把它放在脖子上的吊坠里。她把它带到这儿给你们看了。不，它是，所以她对我说，把它扔进海里。我说，我才不会扔掉我的……我不会……
Imagine my father's eye washing. Your dad's never seen the ocean. He loved the ocean. So what did you do with the eyes? My question. What did you do? Well, I got it sitting in a box. Yes, of course you do.
想象一下我父亲的眼睛被冲走。你爸从没见过大海。他热爱大海。那你怎么处理那些眼睛的？我的问题。你做了什么？好吧，我把它放在盒子里。是的，你当然会。
You got a whole... You don't tossing in the fucking ocean? No, you're at... No, my mom... You brought yours on stage. My mom... Same. We weren't allowed to ask about it.
你有一整套……你没把它扔进该死的大海里？不，你……不，我妈……你把你的带到了舞台上。我妈……一样。我们不被允许问这件事。
Irish Catholic, same as Jewish. You just don't talk. You stuff it all down. Yeah. And you laugh at all. Irish Catholic, same as Jewish. Absolutely. We got our quote.
爱尔兰天主教徒，和犹太人一样。就是不谈论。你把一切都压在心底。是的。然后你嘲笑这一切。爱尔兰天主教徒，和犹太人一样。绝对是。我们有我们的名言。
That's the title of this episode. And so my mom... There are a few difference between Irish Catholic. Just a couple. But not gays and shoes. Right. But so my mom, we weren't allowed to... So my whole life was like, I'd be at the store.
那是这一集的标题。所以我妈……爱尔兰天主教徒之间有一些区别。只有几个。但不是同性恋和鞋子。对。但所以我妈，我们不被允许……所以我整个人生就像，我会在商店里。
And the checkout girl at the counter would be like, staring at my mom's eye. I'm like, mom, they're staring at your eye. Shh, just shut up, right? Right? So then 10 years old, 20 years old, 30 years old, 35 years old. Finally, I'm like, Mom, what happened to your eye? would have, and she still didn't want to talk about it. I found out after she died, she had cancer
柜台的收银员会盯着我妈的眼睛看。我说，妈，他们在盯着你的眼睛看。嘘，闭嘴，对吧？对吧？然后10岁，20岁，30岁，35岁。最后，我说，妈，你的眼睛怎么了？她还是不想谈论。她去世后我才发现，她得了癌症。
in the eye, they took it out, two years old. And then as she grew older, this gets really gross and funny, as she gets older, she gets, my sister and I read the medical reports, they took skin from her vagina to reshape her eye as she grew older, and then my
在眼睛里，两岁时就摘除了。然后随着她长大，这变得非常恶心又好笑，随着她长大，她，我和姐姐读了医疗报告，他们取了她阴道的皮肤来重塑她的眼睛，然后我。
oldest brother goes, I knew when I got upset with her, I wanted to fuck her in the eye. God, it's true. It's true. It's That's it. This show has to be canceled. They're ridiculous.
大哥说，我知道当我生她气时，我想操她的眼睛。天哪，是真的。是真的。就是这样。这节目得被取消。他们太荒谬了。
That is very offensive. I made a terrible joke about that once a long time ago, but I'm not going to repeat it here. By the way, we're all talking about being honest. That's an honest story. That's true story. And that's us making jokes about painful things. Yes. So her complaint after that, she thought that everybody looked like a cunt, right?
那太冒犯了。很久以前我开过一个糟糕的玩笑，但我不会在这里重复。顺便说一句，我们都在谈论诚实。那是一个诚实的故事。那是真实的故事。那是我们拿痛苦的事情开玩笑。是的。所以她在那之后抱怨说，她觉得每个人看起来都像个阴道，对吧？
Isn't that what she said? Did she famously say that? When I was a little kid, I was five years old. There was a guy on my blog. kid on my block five-year-old kid said to me he came up to me said my parents told me your father has a glass eye i was so freaked out yeah we got into a fist fight i did it's probably the only fight i ever won i i i beat him up uh it was crazy and and uh and but i could never ask my father wasn't approachable like that that's why it was so much mystery did you ever get the story um yes i did
她不是这么说的吗？她有名言吗？当我还是个小孩子，五岁的时候。我街区有个家伙。街区里五岁的孩子对我说，他走到我面前说，我父母告诉我你父亲有只义眼。我当时吓坏了，是的，我们打了一架，我赢了，那可能是我唯一赢过的一场架，我打败了他，呃，这太疯狂了，而且，但我从来没法问我父亲，他不是那种容易接近的人，这就是为什么它充满了神秘感。你得到过故事吗？嗯，是的，我得到了。
it's crazy story what happened was i was so curious about the eye and everything about my father because I didn't know him, I would sneak into his room when they would leave the house, which was infrequent. Nobody ever left my house. And you would, you know, so. No one could figure out the lock. My father kept his eye with his porno. So the eyes, my father had porno, you know,
这故事太疯狂了，发生的事情是我对那只眼睛和我父亲的一切都很好奇，因为我不了解他，我会偷偷溜进他的房间，当他们离开家的时候，这很少见。没人离开过我家。你会，你知道，所以。没人能搞定那个锁。我父亲把他的眼睛和他的色情片放在一起。所以眼睛，我父亲有色情片，你知道。
like he had some erotic books and things. You know, if you met my mother, she's not exactly putting out. My mother, one said to me, you know, I prefer to be celibate, but your father has needs. I go, really? That's gross. Oh, but fucking somebody in the eye over then. Go ahead. Those books, no movies, no tapes.
就像他有一些色情书籍之类的东西。你知道，如果你见过我母亲，她并不是那种会主动的人。我母亲有次对我说，你知道，我宁愿禁欲，但你父亲有需求。我说，真的？那太恶心了。哦，但刚才说操眼睛的事。继续。那些书，没有电影，没有录像带。
It was books back then, and the books were wacky, but the eye was staring at me. I wanted to read the erotic books. So I was all freaked out about it, the eye. But then finally... She pops it out to go to sleep. I don't know what went on, but in all seriousness,
那时是书，书很古怪，但那只眼睛盯着我。我想读那些色情书。所以我对它感到很害怕，那只眼睛。但最后……她睡觉时会把它抠出来。我不知道发生了什么，但说真的。
I finally talked to my mother about it. She wouldn't tell me, but I broke her down, and it was a terrible. accident when my father was young he was he put some film in a in a bottle and the bottle exploded he lit it and it exploded in his eye when he was a little kid yeah so and my father had a fabulous attitude about his eye in the sense that he I didn't see any evidence that he saw himself as handicapped you know he did his thing so was he just proud is that the thing he just didn't want to I think he
我终于和我母亲谈了这件事。她不肯告诉我，但我逼问她，那是一次可怕的事故。我父亲年轻时，他把一些胶片放在瓶子里，瓶子爆炸了。他点燃了它，它在他小时候在他眼睛里爆炸了。是的，所以我父亲对他的眼睛有一种极好的态度，因为我没看到任何证据表明他把自己看作残疾人，你知道，他做他自己的事。所以他只是骄傲吗？那是重点吗？他只是不想……我想他。
I think it was a big pain you know it for him in his life seriously a seriously big pain you know wow and yeah it was a big issue my mom would sleep her eye was constantly open so when she slept she'd be like you know like this and I approached the bed and I'd like mom oh she's sleeping oh no she's not sleeping oh she's away like I didn't know whether
我想那对他来说是个巨大的痛苦，你知道，在他的一生中，说真的，一个巨大的痛苦，你知道，哇，是的，这是一个大问题。我妈睡觉时她的眼睛总是睁着的，所以当她睡觉时，她会像，你知道，像这样，我走近床，我会像，妈，哦，她在睡觉，哦不，她没在睡觉，哦，她醒着，就像我不知道是否。
I'm like can I get a glass of water oh I don't know oh you're sleeping like it was just like that it was crazy and then we would where is the eye now my sister has it in a box is it like a time share you get it
我像，我能喝杯水吗，哦，我不知道，哦，你在睡觉，就像那样，太疯狂了，然后我们会，眼睛现在在哪儿？我姐姐把它放在盒子里，它像个分时度假屋吗？你得到它。
Like, if you wanted for the holidays, you... Yeah, sure, I could do it. She could pass it around. We did, one really quick question. I've said this on the show before. But we used to take my mom, used to go bowling on Thursday nights, and we used to go upstairs. We used to invite friends over, and we'd had a chain on the door,
就像，如果你假期想要它，你……是的，当然，我可以。她可以传阅它。我们确实，一个很快的问题。我以前在节目里说过。但我们过去常带我妈去，周四晚上去打保龄球，我们过去常去楼上。我们过去常邀请朋友过来，我们在门上装了链条。
and we'd go upstairs and get her extra eye. She had two in the box, and we'd get her, and they knock on the door, knock, knock, knock. And we'd open it just as much as the chain would go, and we'd stick the eye out and go, who's there? With the eye? Anyway.
我们去楼上拿她多余的眼睛。她在盒子里有两个，我们拿到它，他们敲门，敲，敲，敲。我们只把门打开到链条允许的程度，我们把眼睛伸出去说，谁在那儿？带着眼睛？总之。
I wouldn't have risk that in my house. That's fun. Yeah, it is fun. It's fun but dangerous, if you knew my dad. Tell me about Italy and Jimmy Kimmel. Did you like Italy? I know you didn't want to go. I'll give you an exclusive.
我不会在我家冒那个险。那很有趣。是的，它很有趣。它很有趣但很危险，如果你了解我爸的话。跟我说说意大利和吉米·坎摩尔。你喜欢意大利吗？我知道你不想去。我给你一个独家消息。
Yeah. It was, and this is the most boring answer ever. It was actually a bad question because I loved it. I don't have anything to bitch about. You didn't think you were going to love it. No way. I don't like to travel. I'm perfectly happy sitting at home.
是的。这是有史以来最无聊的回答。这其实是个坏问题，因为我爱死它了。我没什么可抱怨的。你没想过你会喜欢它。不可能。我不喜欢旅行。我坐在家里就很开心。
And if I want to see Italy, I'll go on the internet and look at pictures. Yeah. I mean, I did. But, you know. I went to Paris once and I was like the Eiffel Tower and I saw it. I'm like, got it, ready to go home. Yeah, that looks like the movies and the postcards got it. It looks the same.
如果我想看意大利，我会上网看照片。是的。我是说，我看了。但是，你知道。我去过一次巴黎，我当时想，埃菲尔铁塔，我看到了。我当时想，好了，准备回家了。是的，看起来和电影和明信片里的一样，好了。看起来一样。
Yeah, we, we had a great time. Did Jimmy and Molly somehow convince you and Beth that this is going to be great? No, I had said, you know, my wife wanted to, you know, I wanted to be a human being for my wife. I mean, I can't be in a marriage. And if my wife wants to travel, I can't say, well, go ahead. Once a year, she gets out. So you go. And we ended up having a very very.
是的，我们，我们玩得很开心。吉米和莫莉是怎么说服你和贝丝这会很棒的？不，我说过，你知道，我妻子想，你知道，我想为我妻子做一个正常人。我是说，我不能在婚姻里这样。如果我妻子想旅行，我不能说，好吧，你去吧。一年一次，她出去。所以你去吧。我们最终度过了一个非常非常。
Very romantic time, honey, right? Romantic. Romance was in the air. Romance happened. Barely confirming that, listen. I know. Poor woman. Imagine, you know, think about it.
非常浪漫的时光，亲爱的，对吧？浪漫。空气中弥漫着浪漫。浪漫发生了。勉强确认一下，听着。我知道。可怜的女人。想象一下，你知道，想想看。
That was a nod. Imagine, you know, imagine me crawling on top of you. In Florence. I mean... Okay. It's like a praying mantis attacking you. So, I felt for the woman. I did.
那是一个点头。想象一下，你知道，想象我爬在你身上。在佛罗伦萨。我是说……好吧。就像一只螳螂在攻击你。所以，我为那个女人感到难过。我真的。
But she's a good sport. She took her like a champ. Jesus, right. I felt horrible. I felt horrible. But honey, it wasn't so bad, right? It was over quick. You're the king of the insects.
但她是个好运动。她像个冠军一样接受了它。天哪，对。我感到很糟糕。我感到很糟糕。但亲爱的，没那么糟，对吧？很快就结束了。你是昆虫之王。
You're like, woo. Yeah, yeah. It's like, oh, like the fly, brindle fly, you know. Howard, do you have any, is there any one interview you have that you regret? Is there anyone that you're like, oh, many, many, yeah. What's the one you regret the most? Well, because I was an asshole, many times. But, you know, when I was on regular radio, terrestrial radio, whatever you want to call it,
你就像，呜。是的，是的。就像，哦，像苍蝇，牛虻，你知道。霍华德，你有任何，有没有哪次采访是你后悔的？有没有哪个人让你觉得，哦，很多，很多，是的。你最后悔的是哪一个？好吧，因为我曾经是个混蛋，很多次。但是，你知道，当我在常规广播，地面广播，无论你怎么称呼它时。
I didn't have the faith that if I did an interview that my audience would hold, we had something like a 10-share number one in New York, and I thought, well, if someone comes on the air and they're talking, I could hear the radio's clicking off, that the only thing that might be compelling is if, you know, I was doing my thing.
我没有信心，如果我做一次采访，我的听众会坚持听，我们在纽约有大约10个份额的第一名，我想，好吧，如果有人上节目在说话，我能听到收音机在关掉，唯一可能引人注目的就是，你知道，我在做我自己的事。
Right. Which means I was not trusting of other people, that other people might have talent. So there were people, and I've written about this, the fabulous, most wonderful Robin Williams, for example, came on my show. Oh, yeah. And I just was ridiculously insulting.
对。这意味着我不信任其他人，其他人可能有才华。所以有些人，我写过这个，比如美妙的、最棒的罗宾·威廉姆斯，来到我的节目。哦，是的。我只是荒谬地侮辱人。
And why? Because I was trying to be funny. Robin Williams is way funnier than I am. Let him be funny. But being the insecure child that I was. And somehow having some connection with an audience where I was intuitive and thinking I could hear when they're turning off the radios,
为什么？因为我想变得有趣。罗宾·威廉姆斯比我有趣得多。让他有趣吧。但我是一个缺乏安全感的孩子。并且以某种方式与听众建立了联系，我凭直觉认为我可以听到他们什么时候关掉收音机。
if somebody gave a long answer or wasn't moving fast enough, If the rhythm wasn't right, I could hear the radio's clicking off. And so I really had no business having guests on. It's funny, you're really honest about that in your self-assessment of that time in your life, now that you're older. And is that just a result of getting older? Or is this a result of doing a lot of working? It's a result of leaving terrestrial radio and going to satellite.
如果有人回答得很长或者动作不够快，如果节奏不对，我能听到收音机在关掉。所以我真的没资格请嘉宾。有趣的是，你对自己生命中那个时期的自我评估非常诚实，现在你老了。这只是变老的结果吗？还是做了大量工作的结果？这是离开地面广播去卫星广播的结果。
It suddenly dawned on me. I work for a company now that has 100-something channels. as long as the person who's paying for a subscription is happy with the product and if they're listening to me and I'm doing a long-form interview and if it's not their cup of tea, they can go to a different channel on our service and that freed me, that liberated me
我突然意识到。我现在为一家拥有100多个频道的公司工作。只要付订阅费的人对产品满意，如果他们在听我说话，而我正在做长篇采访，如果这不是他们的菜，他们可以去我们服务的不同频道，这解放了我，这释放了我。
because it wasn't about me necessarily holding the audience. If you enjoy listening to Robin Williams, great, then we have you as a listener. But if you don't, there's a million other choices on satellite. But don't you also find that you're, you're no longer, your agenda is no longer to provide a show for your listener. But instead, perhaps you hope that the people remaining listening to you on that particular day happen to be as interested in the person you're talking to as you are.
因为这不一定是我要留住听众。如果你喜欢听罗宾·威廉姆斯，太好了，那我们就有你作为听众。但如果你不喜欢，卫星上有成千上万种其他选择。但你难道不也发现，你不再，你的议程不再是为你的听众提供节目。而是，也许你希望那天剩下的听众和你一样对你正在交谈的人感兴趣。
In other words, you're not... That's right. Yeah, and it's a more honest sort of, you're not pushing, you're not pressing, you're just... Yes, but you couldn't have done that. If you guys started your radio, let's say you started a career in radio back in the day, this format would not have lasted. It would not be on the radio. It doesn't hold an audience en masse.
换句话说，你不是……没错。是的，这是一种更诚实的，你不是在推，你不是在压，你只是……是的，但你做不到。如果你们开始你们的广播，假设你们很久以前就开始了广播生涯，这种形式是不会持续下去的。它不会在广播上。它无法大规模留住听众。
Jimmy Fallon's sitting in our audience, right? When he does an interview, he can't do an hour interview. He's got to sit there because he's dealing with televisions coming on and off and on and off. We're in a unique position. The period of time we're in right now has allowed us to sit here and have a real conversation and we can play to a niche audience. and so, you know, not to get too academic about it, radio, the old format of radio is gone.
吉米·法伦坐在我们的观众席里，对吧？当他做采访时，他不能做一小时的采访。他必须坐在那儿，因为他在处理电视机开开关关。我们处于一个独特的位置。我们现在所处的时期允许我们坐在这里进行真正的对话，我们可以迎合小众听众。所以，你知道，不是要太学术化，广播，旧的广播形式已经消失了。
And I recognized that when I came to satellite, and I felt that was the innovation. I could sit and have a real conversation with someone like Robin Williams. And I have regrets that, yeah, the format helped me to evolve. Right. I have an actual question for Jimmy, you know, seriously. Seriously, no, to that point.
当我来到卫星广播时，我意识到了这一点，我觉得那是创新。我可以坐下来和像罗宾·威廉姆斯这样的人进行真正的对话。我感到后悔的是，是的，这种形式帮助我进化了。对。我有一个实际的问题要问吉米，你知道，说真的。说真的，不，说到那一点。
No offense, but I think I'm the interview. You'd be great. I guess I just haven't delivered the goods. Jimmy, why don't you take over? This always happens. Always happens. Why don't you get up and do a few Gilbert God freedom pressures? Go ahead, pal.
冒犯了，但我认为我是采访者。你会很棒的。我想我只是没能交付成果。吉米，你为什么不接手？这总是发生。总是发生。你为什么不站起来做几个吉尔伯特·戈特弗里德的印象？继续，伙计。
It has everything to do with what you just said, which is Johnny Carson. You used to have long, long, long interviews, 20 minutes, half hour. And so, Jimmy, I was thinking about you because you're one of the best at what you do. Thank you for standing. Have you ever had discussions about what Howard is
这和你刚才说的一切有关，那就是约翰尼·卡森。你过去常有很长很长的采访，20分钟，半小时。所以，吉米，我一直在想你，因为你是你所做事情中最棒的人之一。谢谢你的站立。你有没有讨论过霍华德正在。
saying about instead of the six, seven minutes you do. Oh, right, you don't have a microphone. Oh, he's coming up to his station. Listen, he's never going to leave. You know that. Once Jimmy comes on. They got a bike for him now. Look at the Fallon mic.
说的关于代替你做的六、七分钟。哦，对，你没有麦克风。哦，他要走到他的位置了。听着，他永远不会离开。你知道的。一旦吉米上来。他们现在为他准备了一辆自行车。看那个法伦麦克风。
I love this. Jimmy. I love it. Yeah. Come on, Jimmy. God bless you. Come on, Jimmy. Can I leave now?
我喜欢这个。吉米。我喜欢它。是的。来吧，吉米。上帝保佑你。来吧，吉米。我现在能离开吗？
No. No. Do you ever have the discussion about changing your format to do kind of where this feels like it's going, which is long-form interviews as opposed to six seven minutes? No, you can't do it. I wish that I could do a longer interview with certain guests. But yeah, but I do wish that I can get into it and talk for an hour. I'm jealous when I, you know, can listen to you.
不。不。你有没有讨论过改变你的形式去做这种感觉像是要走向的地方，也就是长篇采访，而不是六七分钟？不，你做不到。我希望我能和某些嘉宾做更长的采访。但是的，我确实希望我能深入其中并谈论一个小时。当我，你知道，能听你的时候，我很嫉妒。
When you hear a real conversation. Yeah, I love it. Because when it gets going, it's great. And even with an audience, like you said, like, we're loving this. But here's the good news. When I'm in the mood for what you provide and what Kimmel provides, what Colbert provide, you guys do it better than anyone. You don't even forget about the other guys.
当你听到真正的对话时。是的，我喜欢它。因为当它开始时，它很棒。即使有观众，就像你说的，就像，我们喜欢这个。但这是好消息。当我心情好时，对于你提供的和坎摩尔提供的，科尔伯特提供的，你们做得比任何人都好。你甚至不用管其他人。
I don't know. But when I'm in the mood for a long-form thing, it's like there's no one better, you know? Thank you. Thank you. How much do you choose? Thank you, Jimmy. Jimmy, one Gilbert Godfried impression.
我不知道。但当我心情好想听长篇内容时，就像没有人比这更好，你知道？谢谢。谢谢。你选择了多少？谢谢你，吉米。吉米，一个吉尔伯特·戈特弗里德的印象。
For Christ's sake. Thank you. I want to say my wife, my beautiful wife, Paula, is in the audience. She dated you when you were 14. Anyway, you haven't talked to her in a couple years. Give her a call. Paula Chablin. I love Jimmy very much, by the way.
看在上帝的份上。谢谢。我想说我的妻子，我美丽的妻子，宝拉，在观众席里。她和你14岁时约会过。总之，你已经几年没跟她说话了。给她打个电话。宝拉·查布林。顺便说一句，我非常爱吉米。
I want to tell you. Jimmy. Who doesn't love Jimmy? Fallon. I'll let you in on his secret. And Nancy Giovonan. Oh, Nancy's the best. Jimmy and I are going to go camping together on a beach and
我想告诉你。吉米。谁不爱吉米？法伦。我会告诉你他的秘密。还有南希·乔瓦南。哦，南希是最棒的。吉米和我打算一起去海滩露营，而且。
it's just going to be the two of us alone. Jimmy, right, we're going to be in a, what is that called? An RV? An air stream. Wow. Yeah. How much of your... He thinks I'm going to go. How many of your guests? Because one of the other things that we get to do is we get to choose, we reach out to people that
只有我们两个人单独。吉米，对，我们要去一个，那叫什么？房车？气流房车。哇。是的。你的多少……他以为我要去。你的多少嘉宾？因为我们能做的另一件事是我们能选择，我们联系我们。
we're interested in talking to. How much of that do you do and how much of that comes in through... We reach out to some people, but mostly... And this is probably to our detriment, but I don't want to have a lot of guests. We just... We keep a limited amount.
感兴趣交谈的人。你做了多少，有多少是通过……我们联系一些人，但主要是……这可能对我们有害，但我不想有很多嘉宾。我们只是……我们保持有限的数量。
I think some of our strongest shows when we're just sitting and doing our own thing. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. I have to say, I tried to be a guest on your show for so many years. I kept asking my publicist every year. Just hoping, like, are things good enough
我认为我们最强的一些节目是我们只是坐着做我们自己的事。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。我必须说，我尝试在你的节目里做嘉宾很多年了。我每年都一直问我的公关。只是希望，就像，事情是否足够好。
in my career where maybe I could be... I remember... It wasn't bad. No, no, no. But I once got... My public said, listen, Jason, we got news back.
在我的职业生涯中，也许我可以成为……我记得……那并不坏。不，不，不。但我曾经得到……我的公关说，听着，杰森，我们得到消息了。
It's good news, bad news. Good news is, he says he's a fan. Bad news is, he says he just genuinely really has nothing he would like to know. No, no, no.
有好消息，坏消息。好消息是，他说他是粉丝。坏消息是，他说他真的没什么他想知道的。不，不，不。
But, you know, I'm paraphrasing. But it was absolutely true. You know what I was like, I said, honestly, and I've said this to Jason, I said, look, I could Google you and find out enough stuff.
但是，你知道，我在转述。但这绝对是真的。你知道我是什么样的，我说，老实说，我告诉过杰森，我说，看，我可以谷歌你并找出足够多的东西。
I don't really need to sit and talk to you. You're not about anybody. Really. I'd rather talk to a... Stop it. No, no, no, but seriously, it's much more interesting talking to somebody who's got, like, a weird, fucked up...
我真的不需要坐下来和你谈。你不是关于任何人的。真的。我宁愿和……别说了。不，不，不，但说真的，和有某种奇怪的、搞砸了的人交谈更有趣……
Here's the thing. If I did a show every day where I just interviewed one guest, that would be fascinating me. But there's also an audience in my group that likes to hear us doing, you know, bits and schick and, like, sitting and talking, Robin and I'm just talking.
事情是这样的。如果我每天做一个节目，我只采访一个嘉宾，那对我来说会很迷人。但我的团队里也有听众喜欢听我们做，你知道，片段和噱头，就像，坐着谈话，罗宾和我只是在谈话。
And I recognize that. So I don't overload the show with a lot of guests. but sometimes we do reach out like you know I wanted Joe Biden on so we had him on and I wanted
我意识到了这一点。所以我不会用很多嘉宾来塞满节目。但有时我们确实会联系，就像你知道，我想要乔·拜登上节目，所以我们请了他，我想要。
Bruce Springsteen I begged him to come on I just wanted to come on yeah yeah that's the white whale it was unbelievable he was sitting in a room
布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，我求他来，我只是想让他来，是的，是的，那是白鲸，这太不可思议了，他坐在一个房间里。
with Bruce and he's doing a concert basically and talking about how he creates songs yeah so you know we do we do reach out and there are people I just love to talk to do you miss playing music at all
和布鲁斯在一起，他基本上在开音乐会，谈论他是如何创作歌曲的，是的，所以你知道，我们确实，我们确实联系了，有些人我只是喜欢交谈。你怀念弹音乐吗？
like being a disjockey no it never was about You know, it's weird. I play music and I talk over it. Yeah, yeah. So, you know, it's like I can't play. When I got into radio, I was a disc jockey. You know, straight disc jockey.
就像做个唱片骑师，不，从来不是关于。你知道，这很奇怪。我播放音乐，我在上面说话。是的，是的。所以，你知道，就像我不能弹。当我进入广播时，我是个唱片骑师。你知道，直率的唱片骑师。
My father would say, first you must learn to be a straight disc jockey. Not all that nonsense you do. So I went on the radio and be like, hi, this is Howard Stern, WR&W, progressive music from the woods. And this is Crosby Still's Nash and Young. And so, you know, we would do that.
我父亲会说，首先你必须学会做一个直率的唱片骑师。不是你做的那些废话。所以我上了广播，就像，嗨，我是霍华德·斯特恩，WR&W，来自森林的进步音乐。这是克罗斯比、斯蒂尔斯、纳什和杨。所以，你知道，我们会那样做。
And I hated it. I hated it. Even you had to segue, you had to play a record and make sure there was no dead air. It was no autonomy. You couldn't launch bands. You had to play. Oh, no, no, I played whatever I wanted. But it was horrible.
我讨厌它。我讨厌它。即使你必须衔接，你必须播放唱片并确保没有死气。没有自主权。你不能推出乐队。你必须播放。哦，不，不，我播放任何我想播放的。但那太可怕了。
I mean, it was a lot of pressure. You had to get the commercials lined up. It was just you in a little room in a house somewhere up in the woods. It was, you know, these are these shitty radio stations, $96 a week. And you played records and you announced them. And this is what I did. And I was the worst at it. I was the worst.
我是说，压力很大。你必须把广告排好。那只是你一个人在森林里某个房子里的小房间里。那是，你知道，这些是糟糕的广播电台，每周96美元。你播放唱片并宣布它们。这就是我做的。我是最差的。我是最差的。
There were no performers in my family. I didn't understand performance. I was not in show business. My father even said, You cannot be unladial. You have no elucution. You do not enunciate. You read nothing.
我的家庭里没有表演者。我不理解表演。我不在演艺圈。我父亲甚至说，你不能成为电台主持人。你没有口才。你不发音。你什么都不读。
You did have some sense that you... I had no sense. You had a sense that your personality might be halfway entertaining. I didn't know. Between that and the music, When I'd walk around college, nobody seemed to pay attention to me. I think I had the worst person out.
你确实有一些感觉你……我没有任何感觉。你有一种感觉，你的个性可能有一半是娱乐性的。我不知道。在那和音乐之间，当我走在大学里时，似乎没人注意我。我想我有个性最差的。
You had no confidence that you were going to be somewhat compelling at all. I would write letters to my girlfriend saying, I will be the world's greatest radio performer. Why did you think that? I have no idea. I don't know. I just knew that there was something there. Well, you weren't always, sorry.
你没有任何信心你会变得有点引人注目。我会写信给我的女朋友说，我将成为世界上最伟大的广播表演者。你为什么那么想？我不知道。我不知道。我只是知道那里有什么东西。好吧，你并不总是，抱歉。
So you weren't always this charismatic. You weren't always this comfortable in talking. No, it took me years. That's why I resent this podcast. you guys are just on here talking. I had to spend years. I had to spend years. Four years.
所以你并不总是这么有魅力。你并不总是这么舒服地交谈。不，我花了好几年。这就是为什么我讨厌这个播客。你们只是在这里谈话。我不得不花几年。我不得不花几年。四年。
It took me 10 years just to get conversational. It was very slow. You guys are too talented. No, no, no, but in all seriousness. Playing records was horrible. Were you a fan of music, though? Oh, huge fan of music. You know, music meant more to me than religion.
我花了10年才变得健谈。这非常慢。你们太有才华了。不，不，不，但说真的。播放唱片太可怕了。不过你是音乐迷吗？哦，巨大的音乐迷。你知道，音乐对我来说比宗教意义重大。
I never got a thing out of religion. But man, when I'd hear the Beatles or the stones or George Harrison, you know, my sweet Lord, That stuff, that spoke to me. That moved me. And I was happy to launch a lot of bands. I was a program director for a while.
我从来没从宗教里得到什么。但伙计，当我听到披头士或滚石或乔治·哈里森，你知道，我的甜美上帝，那些东西，那对我说话。那感动了我。我很乐意推出很多乐队。我当过一段时间的项目总监。
And I didn't even understand. I didn't know anything. A guy from a record company would call me up and he'd go, would you play our record? I go, sure. He goes, no, no, no, I'll play it for you. You don't have to play it for me. I'll report it to Billboard.
我甚至不理解。我什么都不知道。唱片公司的一个人会打电话给我，他会说，你会播放我们的唱片吗？我说，当然。他说，不，不，不，我为你播放。你不需要为我播放。我会向公告牌报告。
I didn't care. I was happy to help me. Do you guys starstruck around musicians? I admire musicians, and I know how hard they work at it. But is that the group that would, if anyone was going to get you star, that or athletes or musicians? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Who?
我不在乎。我很高兴能帮助我。你们在音乐家面前会感到受宠若惊吗？我钦佩音乐家，我知道他们为此付出了多少努力。但那是如果有人要让你受宠若惊的群体吗，那是运动员还是音乐家？是的，是的，是的。谁？
Who would be, who's the one that you haven't met? You'd be like, uh-oh, I can't talk. Oh, geez. Is it a beetle? Well, I've met Paul. Yeah. I'm Ringo, and they were great on the show. You want to take a temperature over the room about the name of the Beatles?
谁会是，谁是你还没见过的人？你会像，呃-哦，我不能说话。哦，天哪。是披头士吗？好吧，我见过保罗。是的。林戈，他们在节目里很棒。你想在房间里测一下关于披头士名字的温度吗？
Oh, yeah. Do you guys know about this? Oh, old, old captain, brain, brain. What happened, well? Let's take an honest, honest thing of the audience. I didn't know my whole life. I thought it was the insect of the Beatles. I didn't know it was people who make beats.
哦，是的。你们知道这个吗？哦，老，老船长，大脑，大脑。发生了什么，好吧？让我们对观众做一个诚实的，诚实的调查。我一生都不知道。我以为是甲虫的昆虫。我不知道那是制造节拍的人。
The B-A-T. He was like... Clap if you were with me. Thank you. Did not know that till right now. I didn't know what? It just sucked the air out of the room. I want to thank the guys for that story.
B-A-T。他就像……如果你和我在一起就鼓掌。谢谢。直到现在才知道。我不知道什么？它只是把房间里的空气吸干了。我想感谢那些家伙的故事。
Have you noticed the arrow in the FedEx logo? Yeah. I don't know what that means. All right, here's one you didn't know, Sean. Sean, here's one I guarantee you you didn't know. Yeah. You know the place you go for? for roast beef, right? Arby's, right?
你注意到联邦快递标志里的箭头了吗？是的。我不知道那意味着什么。好吧，这里有一个你不知道的，肖恩。肖恩，这里有一个我保证你不知道的。是的。你知道你去的地方吗？为了烤牛肉，对吧？阿比斯，对吧？
Yeah? Why is it called Arbyes? They got the meat or whatever they say. No, no. Think about it. Why is it Arby's? Roast beef. R.B., roast beef. I didn't know that, but I put it together. Arbiz. Oh, I see. Did not know that. Look at Will. We could do this all day long. This is going great.
是吗？为什么叫阿比斯？他们有肉或者他们说的任何东西。不，不。想想看。为什么是阿比斯？烤牛肉。R.B.，烤牛肉。我不知道，但我把它拼在一起了。阿比斯。哦，我明白了。不知道那个。看威尔。我们可以整天做这个。这进行得很顺利。
Now wait, so speaking, speaking of really, really glad I came on. By the way, these guys treat it like it's a TV show. I'm in a trailer. I'm waiting to come on. There's a warm-up act for the audience. I don't know from this. You just go on the radio. First of all, I don't think we've said it yet. I can't thank you enough for doing this. You don't do this.
现在等等，所以说到，说到真的，真的很高兴我来了。顺便说一句，这些家伙把它当作电视节目对待。我在拖车里。我在等上场。观众有一个热身表演。我不知道这个。你只是上广播。首先，我不认为我们还没说出来。我怎么感谢你都不为过。你不做这个。
I've seen you do it for Letterman. I've seen you do it for Kimmel. You don't do this, and I can't thank you enough. I'm happy to be here. Thank you. Happy to be here. We really do, and just so you're not just hearing it from Jason, that you are the gold standard for us,
我见过你为莱特曼做。我见过你为坎摩尔做。你不做这个，我怎么感谢你都不为过。我很高兴来到这里。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。我们真的，只是为了让你不只是从杰森那里听到，你是我们的黄金标准。
and you're the guy that we always wanted to get. We talk about you all the time. And honestly, this is a big deal first. Well, I'm really honored. And Will, much to your point, for many years, I couldn't take a compliment, but I do appreciate you guys. I got a new one for you. Okay. Everybody knows you're recently 70.
你是我们一直想得到的人。我们一直谈论你。老实说，这是一个大事件。好吧，我真的很荣幸。威尔，说到你的点，很多年来，我无法接受赞美，但我确实感谢你们。我有一个新的给你。好吧。每个人都知道你最近70岁了。
It's unbelievable. It's so fucked up. No, no, no. You have not changed. Oh, God. Beth, back me up here. Like, what are you guys doing? I know you're not out there, like, running 10 miles on the beach every day.
这太不可思议了。这太搞砸了。不，不，不。你没变。哦，上帝。贝丝，在这里支持我。就像，你们在做什么？我知道你不在外面，就像，每天在海滩上跑10英里。
Is it just jeans? I mean, you look exactly the same. I look terrible. Howard. The only thing I will say... You don't look exactly the same for the last 30 years? I can't even see a picture, but I will tell you one thing. I do not color my hair.
只是牛仔裤吗？我是说，你看起来完全一样。我看起来很糟糕。霍华德。我唯一要说的是……你过去30年看起来没完全一样吗？我甚至看不到照片，但我会告诉你一件事。我不染头发。
No, I know, I can tell you. I don't. This is it. And I have a gray beard. He doesn't either. You don't color your hair, right? No. But you don't have, you're supposed to have like a belly.
不，我知道，我能告诉你。我不。就是这样。我有一把灰色的胡子。他也没有。你不染头发，对吧？不。但你没有，你应该有一个像肚子一样的东西。
I do have a belly. I have a belly and tits. You're supposed to, everything's got it. I got a belly and tits, right, honey? You've seen me with my shirt off. She's busy, talking. By the way, same. You want to go turps off?
我确实有一个肚子。我有一个肚子和乳房。你应该，一切都有。我有一个肚子和乳房，对吧，亲爱的？你见过我脱掉衬衫的样子。她很忙，在说话。顺便说一句，一样。你想脱掉吗？
You want to go turps off? Should we go Terps off? No, no, no. But you don't look like you ache or you're sore, I can't fucking... No, no, you seem like you're in great... Are you doing anything that... Well, first of all. I'm painting, let's get into that.
你想脱掉吗？我们应该脱掉吗？不，不，不。但你看起来不像你疼痛或酸痛，我不能该死的……不，不，你看起来好像你在很棒……你在做任何……好吧，首先。我在画画，让我们进入那个。
I do, well, yeah, I do, I paint. I like to paint. It's incredible the painting here. I don't know if you guys... Does it people know? Okay. And the photography, it's like... And the tiny sketching with the magnifying glass.
我做，好吧，是的，我做，我画画。我喜欢画画。这里的画太不可思议了。我不知道你们……人们知道吗？好吧。还有摄影，就像……还有用放大镜进行的小素描。
I like it. I don't use a magnifying glass. No more? No, I never did. I never used a magnifying glass. I saw your drafting thing. there was something. Yeah, I have a big magnify, but I don't use it for that.
我喜欢它。我不使用放大镜。不再用了？不，我从来没用过。我从来没用过放大镜。我看到了你的绘图东西。有东西。是的，我有一个大的放大镜，但我不用它做那个。
Okay. I'm just telling you. But it was there. I mean, I'm not fucking crazy. No, you know, it was there. It was there. But, yeah, I enjoy those things. I mean, it's really cool.
好吧。我只是告诉你。但它在那儿。我是说，我没疯。不，你知道，它在那儿。它在那儿。但是，是的，我享受那些事情。我是说，这真的很酷。
When did you start playing guitar? Okay. Short version. I'll tell you why I play guitar. And I'm going to blame Jimmy Fallon. You're going to jam with jelly roll tonight? No, no, no, no. Jimmy stand up.
你什么时候开始弹吉他的？好吧。简短版本。我会告诉你为什么我弹吉他。我要责怪吉米·法伦。你今晚要和果冻卷即兴演奏吗？不，不，不，不。吉米站起来。
There we go. Jimmy Fallon. Jimmy Fallon says to me. You're kidding me. Here's what happened. Ten years ago, I turned 60, and I said I either want to play the guitar, or I want to learn to paint.
这就对了。吉米·法伦。吉米·法伦对我说。你在开玩笑吧。这是发生的事情。十年前，我60岁了，我说我要么想弹吉他，要么想学画画。
Oh, and you did that. I never drew, I never, you know, there ain't. For some reason, I had, I wanted to paint in the worst way. So that's all in 10 years. And I began to, yeah, I began to study watercolor, and I really focused on it. I mean, and you know as a pianist that you have to, you have to, you just have to focus on it.
哦，你做了。我从来没画过，我从来没，你知道，没有。出于某种原因，我，我非常想画画。所以那都在10年里。我开始，是的，我开始学习水彩画，我真的专注于它。我是说，而且你作为钢琴家知道你必须，你必须，你只是必须专注于它。
It's not that people have some sort of natural ability. It's the work. You have to work out. People go, oh, I don't have that. I'm a good focus on the penis his whole life. Yeah. I'm an expert. Just two laughs for that.
这不是人们有某种天赋。这是工作。你必须锻炼。人们说，哦，我没有那个。我一生都专注于阴茎。是的。我是专家。只有两个笑声。
I thought that was pretty good. It's a tough pretty good. We'll sweeten that in the edit. It's okay to laugh. But, you know, anyway, I enjoy those things. But I applaud you wanting to research and find other things. Not that you are older. Like, 70 is not old.
我觉得那段挺好的。虽然有点难，但还不错。我们会在剪辑时润色一下。笑出来没关系。不过，总之，我很享受这些。但我很赞赏你想要去研究和寻找其他事物的想法。并不是说你老了。70岁并不算老。
but that you pursue things that still challenge you. Somebody your age is willing to do new things, is what you're saying. Well, it's true. And by the way, that fucks my head up. Because what I said to my wife, I want to learn guitar. But I feel foolish because of my age, like, what am I trying to do here?
而是你还在追求挑战自己的事物。你的意思是，像你这个年纪的人还愿意尝试新事物。嗯，确实如此。顺便说一句，这让我很困惑。因为我跟我妻子说，我想学吉他。但我因为自己的年龄感到愚蠢，心想，我到底在折腾什么？
I don't want to be a rock star. I just want to understand music. Challenge yourself to a new hobby. Because I love musicians, and I love what they do, and I want to understand that language. Let's do a duet sometime, piano and guitar. Do you play miniat?
我不想成为摇滚明星。我只是想理解音乐。挑战自己去培养一个新爱好。因为我热爱音乐人，热爱他们所做的一切，我想理解那种语言。我们什么时候来个二重奏吧，钢琴加吉他。你会弹吗？
wet and G. I do. All right. Then we can do it. Are you playing classical? Are you playing classical guitar? No, but I don't play classical guitar. Yeah, I'm starting 12-string guitar, man. No, no, no, no.
湿的和G调。我会。好吧。那我们就能合作了。你弹古典吗？你在弹古典吉他吗？不，我不弹古典吉他。是的，我正在学12弦吉他，伙计。不，不，不，不。
It hurts the fingers, though, doesn't it? Well, look at my, look at the tips of my fingers. Look at those calluses. Oh, my God. Yeah. So, how much do you play a day? Well, I'm on vacation now, so I can play. From guitar? No, from work.
不过那很伤手指，对吧？嗯，看看我的，看看我的指尖。看看那些老茧。天哪。是的。那你一天练多久？嗯，我现在在度假，所以我可以练。练吉他？不，从工作中休假。
I'm on vacation from work. Okay. So I can play, some days, five, six hours. Really? What? So you must be good now. Who's your favorite? Who's your favorite guitarist? Oh, Jesus.
我正在休假。好的。所以我有时一天能练五六个小时。真的吗？什么？那你现在一定很厉害了。你最喜欢谁？你最喜欢的吉他手是谁？哦，天哪。
Just name one of them, a few of them. Well, I mean, you got to say Hendricks. You got to say Jimmy Page. I mean, Jimmy Page, now I have even more appreciation for Jimmy Page. I was playing one of the most beautiful love songs, thank you, by Zeppelin. And the intro to that. And you sit and you realize this guy wrote this. Yes, excellent.
随便说一个，或者几个。嗯，我是说，你肯定得提亨德里克斯。你得提吉米·佩奇。我是说，吉米·佩奇，我现在对吉米·佩奇有了更多的欣赏。我当时在弹齐柏林飞艇乐队那首最美的情歌之一，《谢谢你》。还有那首歌的前奏。你坐下来就会意识到，这家伙写出了这个。是的，太棒了。
Excellent. Thanks, guys. Was that you singing or playing the guitar? Keep that applause. But you realize how brilliant it is. And in order to get to that level, you've got to play every day for hours and hours. And I'm mad at myself because when I was younger, I didn't allow myself to practice music, where Sean did, when he was smart about it. Well, when I was younger, I had so many, I don't know why I reacted this way, but so many adults,
太棒了。谢谢你们，伙计们。刚才那是你在唱歌还是在弹吉他？保持掌声。但你意识到它有多么天才。为了达到那个水平，你必须每天练习好几个小时。我很生自己的气，因为我年轻的时候，没有让自己去练习音乐，而肖恩做到了，他在这一点上很聪明。嗯，我年轻的时候，有太多，我不知道为什么会有这种反应，但有太多的成年人，
when they found out when I was like five, six, seven, eight years old playing piano practicing, they'd go, oh, you know what? I wish I would have stuck with it over and over and over all these adults telling me that. So I was like, there must be something to that. So that's what made me stick to it. Was there something?
当他们发现我五、六、七、八岁时在练习钢琴，他们会说，哦，你知道吗？我真希望我当时坚持下来了，一遍又一遍，所有这些成年人都这样告诉我。所以我心想，这一定有什么道理。所以这就是我坚持下来的原因。真的有什么道理吗？
Was there a fork in the road where had you stuck with that instead of radio, you would have been that? It had to be radio for me. So it was never like architecture. No, I announced my family. I will be on the radio. Which was ridiculous.
有没有一个岔路口，如果你坚持那个而不是广播，你就会成为那样的人？对我来说，必须是广播。所以从来没有想过建筑之类的。不，我向家人宣布。我要去广播电台工作。这太荒谬了。
It doesn't make any sense. I don't understand it. But your dad was a sound engineer. Yeah. Well, he was a radio. radio engineer. So that part of it made sense. Yeah, but listen, my father didn't spend a lot of time paying attention to me or interacting with me. And I used to sit. Mine did. Well, I would watch him. He was focused on you.
这根本说不通。我不明白。但你父亲是音响工程师。是的。嗯，他是广播工程师。所以那部分说得通。是的，但听着，我父亲并没有花太多时间关注我或与我互动。我过去常坐着。我的父亲会。嗯，我会看着他。他专注于你。
No, but I, but he would, he would, when I would see him commuting to work, and he put the radio on him, Bob Grant was on, who was this conservative broadcaster, but the guy was mesmerizing on the radio. And I saw the way my father listened and shushed me, told me to shut the fuck up, so he could hear Bob Grant. Shut up! I said, so that's how you get. That's how you get someone's attention. Get on the radio.
不，但我，但他会，他会，当我看到他通勤去上班时，他会打开收音机，鲍勃·格兰特在节目里，他是一位保守派广播员，但那家伙在广播里非常迷人。我看到我父亲听节目的样子，他让我安静，让我闭嘴，这样他就能听鲍勃·格兰特。闭嘴！我说，原来这就是你吸引别人注意的方式。去广播电台。
You did it to get your dad's attention. I think so, yeah. Sorry, just to follow up on that, if you don't mind, Jesus Christ. Sorry. Do you think, what was the moment where your dad, I mean, obviously you had an incredible success in radio? Was there a moment where he, like, was there an actual moment where he went, holy shit, Howard? I think my mother put him out. You know, he just said, oh, oh, oh, yeah.
你做这个是为了引起你父亲的注意。我想是的，没错。抱歉，只是想跟进一下，如果你不介意的话，天哪。抱歉。你认为，你父亲意识到你——我是说，显然你在广播界取得了巨大的成功——有没有一个时刻，他真的觉得，天哪，霍华德？我想是我母亲让他意识到这一点的。你知道，他只是说，哦，哦，哦，是的。
I love you. You know, he was not, my father, my father grew up in the depression. Yeah. He had nothing. When I say nothing, it was like literally no, like no shoes. You know, his father worked in a sweatshop as a pants pressure.
我爱你。你知道，他不是，我父亲，我父亲是在大萧条时期长大的。是的。他一无所有。当我说是“一无所有”时，真的是连鞋子都没有。你知道，他父亲在血汗工厂里当裤子熨烫工。
My father was a very deprived guy. And he didn't have a lot of room for emotion. I think he probably had a lot of bottle up emotion, but he couldn't, he couldn't express it. And he didn't know how. He didn't have the facility. Which, but I would have loved to have known my father. I would have loved to.
我父亲是一个非常匮乏的人。他没有太多表达情感的空间。我想他可能有很多压抑的情感，但他无法，他无法表达出来。他不知道怎么做。他没有那种能力。虽然，但我真的很想了解我的父亲。我真的很想。
Why do you think you're so well-adjustment, I'm not. I'm a mess. I'm still with a psychiatrist. Beth wouldn't be with an idiot. Wouldn't be with an asshole. I didn't say I was an idiot. I said I'm fucked up. You're not. Honey, come up here and tell people how fucked up.
你为什么觉得你调整得这么好，我没有。我一团糟。我还在看心理医生。贝丝不会和一个白痴在一起。不会和一个混蛋在一起。我没说我是白痴。我说我搞砸了。你没有。亲爱的，上来告诉大家我有多糟糕。
Please come up. Well, what do you? She says I'm a lot. Honey, please. You don't want to come up. Do you think, do you, well, but like, I don't think that people know, like, if there was one misconception of you, do you have any idea what that might be?
请上来。嗯，你觉得呢？她说我很难搞。亲爱的，拜托。你不想上来。你觉得，你，嗯，但就像，我不认为人们知道，如果说对你有一个误解，你知道那可能是什么吗？
I mean, I don't know, but I will say that for me, personally, given your edge of humor, it was really exciting to get to know you a little bit and see how incredibly soft and chewy you are on the inside, how incredibly sincere and genuine and attentive you are to the... But what I said was, you know, it was unfair. You just go around saying, oh, well, that's an act on the radio. It was. It was who I was. I had a lot of anger. Obviously, but there's a choice to, like, not be fucked up and just know how to manage that. Yeah, but my attitude about radio, and I say this over and over again, was, I just want to make people laugh.
我是说，我不知道，但我会说，对我个人而言，考虑到你那种尖锐的幽默感，能稍微了解你一点，看到你内心是多么柔软和细腻，看到你有多么真诚、纯粹和专注，这真的很令人兴奋……但我说的是，你知道，这不公平。你只是到处说，哦，好吧，那只是广播里的表演。确实是。那就是我。我当时有很多愤怒。显然，但你可以选择不去搞砸，学会如何管理它。是的，但我对广播的态度，我一遍又一遍地说，就是，我只是想让人发笑。
I want people to have a great time in their car. Whether it's, if it's a compelling interview, great. But if I'm sitting there and I'm being really funny and I'm doing something good, well, you know, that's what I'm trying to do. So I never did anything out of malice. I did it because I thought I was genuinely funny. Right. Was I genuinely funny?
我希望人们在车里能过得开心。如果这是一个引人入胜的采访，那很好。但如果我坐在那里，表现得非常有趣，做了一些好事，嗯，你知道，这就是我努力在做的。所以我从来没有出于恶意做任何事。我这样做是因为我觉得我真的很幽默。对。我真的很有趣吗？
Sometimes, sometimes not. You were speaking the truth. You know, your observations were spot on. It was sometimes painful for folks, and that was a funny part. of that being honest though I remember when you spoke about your health scare about having a little spot on your kidney thank god it was nothing and that was you revealed like that was one of the first one of the few things that you did not share with your audience because you've always been so open and honest with your audience about everything so what is where is that line and is there anything
有时是，有时不是。你在说真话。你知道，你的观察非常到位。这对人们来说有时很痛苦，而那正是诚实带来的有趣之处。我记得你谈到你的健康恐慌，关于肾脏上的一个小点，谢天谢地那没什么，那是你透露的，那是你没有与听众分享的极少数事情之一，因为你总是对听众非常开放和诚实，关于一切，那么那条界限在哪里，有什么东西是……
i'll tell you why and you guys probably know this from from doing this now and having a popular show you know if you go on a radio and you say listen i could potentially i have this thing and they're telling me it could be cancer, a 95% chance. You start to get letters from every know-it-all in the audience. Listen, my mother died. You're fucked, do you, this, you're that. And I'm neurotic. I am neurotic about my health.
我告诉你为什么，你们可能从现在做这个节目中知道这一点，拥有一个受欢迎的节目，你知道，如果你在广播里说，听着，我可能，我有这个东西，他们告诉我可能是癌症，95%的几率。你就会开始收到来自听众中每一个“万事通”的信。听着，我母亲就是这样去世的。你完了，你这个，你那个。而且我很神经质。我对我的健康很神经质。
I don't want to know. Where's Bradley Cooper? I just want to look at him. Come on. Come on, Bradley. Shut up. There he is. There's Bradley.
我不想知道。布莱德利·库珀在哪？我只想看着他。来吧。来吧，布莱德利。闭嘴。他在那儿。那是布莱德利。
Look at that. Son of a bitch. So good looking. He's gorgeous. I love Bradley Cooper. I don't mind saying it. We all do. No, no.
看看那个。狗娘养的。太帅了。他真迷人。我爱布莱德利·库珀。我不介意说出来。我们都爱。不，不。
There are people. Sean doesn't love him. Bradley, I love you. Can I tell you, Bradley Cooper story? We'd love to hear a Bradley story. Can I tell you Bradley Cooper story? If it's positive. One of the greatest moments for me on the show,
有些人。肖恩不爱他。布莱德利，我爱你。我能告诉你一个布莱德利·库珀的故事吗？我们很想听听布莱德利的故事。我能告诉你一个布莱德利·库珀的故事吗？如果是正面的话。对我来说，节目中最伟大的时刻之一，
but personal, because you asked about people I interviewed. I was interviewing Bradley, and at the time, Bradley had just finished a run on Broadway. The Elephant Man. Brilliant. Brilliant. Brilliant. Absolutely, brilliant. And I am a fan of the Elephant Man.
但很私人，因为你问到我采访过的人。我当时在采访布莱德利，那时，布莱德利刚刚结束了百老汇的演出。《象人》。太精彩了。太精彩了。太精彩了。绝对精彩。而且我是《象人》的粉丝。
And Bradley's so serious about the Elephant Man, he goes, you know, I just want you to know, I don't joke about the elephant man. I said, I'm not going to joke, but I would like to do the elephant man for you. Oh, no. And I would love if you would come back as your elephant man. Yeah.
布莱德利对《象人》非常认真，他说，你知道，我只想让你知道，我不拿《象人》开玩笑。我说，我不会开玩笑，但我很想为你表演一下《象人》。哦，不。如果你能以《象人》的身份回来，我会很高兴的。是的。
And so I said, oh, oh, so kind to show me. And sort of kindness, so beautiful. And Bradley looked at me, and I said, he's either going to walk out, and he goes, Oh, thank you. And we had a moment where we were both the elephant man, immersed in our character. And it was one of the single biggest highlights.
所以我说，哦，哦，太客气了，展示给我看。那种善意，太美好了。布莱德利看着我，我说，他要么会走出去，结果他说，哦，谢谢。我们有了一个时刻，我们俩都成了象人，沉浸在我们的角色中。这是我职业生涯中最大的亮点之一。
Radio Magic. That is. Radio Magic. You acted up. You got to act with Bradley. I got to act with Bradley Cooper. Very few people. You know, this guy's one of our best actors.
广播魔法。确实是。广播魔法。你演得很好。你和布莱德利演对手戏。我和布莱德利·库珀演了对手戏。很少有人能做到。你知道，这家伙是我们最好的演员之一。
Rarified air. Without a doubt. And he's one of the greatest filmmakers we've got. Myestro is incredible. That's right. And when he saw, he was so inspired. Tell him Bradley how good I was.
稀有的空气。毫无疑问。而且他是我们拥有的最伟大的电影制作人之一。《音乐大师》太不可思议了。没错。当他看到时，他深受启发。告诉他，布莱德利，我演得有多好。
He loved it. Never saw such acting. I've had no training, by the way, as an actor. That's right. That's right. How many times did you audition for private parts? Yeah, because I was going to say, you want to know something about private parts? Here's the funny thing.
他很喜欢。从来没见过这样的表演。顺便说一下，我没有任何表演训练。没错。没错。你为《私密部分》试镜了多少次？是的，因为我正想说，你想知道关于《私密部分》的事吗？有趣的事情是这样的。
So in developing... What a movie, by the way. Thank you. It's a great movie. It's a great movie. It is so good. But I got to tell you a funny story about it because this leads into it. It's insane.
所以在开发……顺便说一句，那部电影真棒。谢谢。那是一部伟大的电影。那是一部伟大的电影。它太好了。但我得告诉你一个关于它的有趣故事，因为这引出了它。这太疯狂了。
So, you know... Closer to the mic, please. So I wrote the book. I wrote the book and I had no clue. When they said they want to make a movie out of it, how am I going to make a movie out of this thing? Before Betty, I was involved in writing some of the scripts.
所以，你知道……靠近麦克风，拜托。所以我写了那本书。我写了那本书，我毫无头绪。当他们说他们想把它拍成电影时，我该怎么把这东西拍成电影？在贝蒂之前，我参与编写了一些剧本。
We had other writers and this and that. There were 25 full drafts of this thing, and each one was worse than the next. And my agent at the time, we just passed away, Don Buck will love. But he said to me, these scripts are so bad,
我们有其他编剧等等。这东西有25个完整草稿，每一个都比上一个更糟。我当时的经纪人，我们刚去世的唐·巴克威尔，他很爱我。但他对我说，这些剧本太烂了，
you'll be laughed out of it. So the movie studio said, Listen. Paramount? We're at the time. Reisher Entertainment put up the money. And Paramount was, the distributor.
你会因为这个被嘲笑的。所以电影公司说，听着。派拉蒙？我们当时在派拉蒙。Reisher Entertainment 出了钱。而派拉蒙是发行商。
And so they said, listen, this is crazy. The money that we're spending on these writers, and you're not accepting any of these scripts, we're going to hire Jeff Goldblum to play you since you won't do that. No way. Is that true? Is that great Jeff Goldblum, by the way.
所以他们说，听着，这太疯狂了。我们在这些编剧身上花的钱，而你又不接受任何剧本，我们要雇杰夫·高布伦来演你，既然你不愿意演。没门。那是真的吗？顺便说一句，那是伟大的杰夫·高布伦。
I said, I looked at me eye, and I said, you know what, I would pay to see that. I would love to see Jeff Goldblum as Howard Sturred. I think you'd be terrific. But anyway. This time, was there a plan for you to play the part? they wanted to actually go in the direction? They were so frustrated with me
我说，我看着我的眼睛，我说，你知道吗，我会花钱去看那个。我很想看杰夫·高布伦演霍华德·斯特恩。我觉得你会很棒。但总之。这次，有没有计划让你演这个角色？他们真的想往那个方向发展吗？他们对我太沮丧了，
because I had written into the contract. And again, this was my agent's brilliance. They couldn't make the movie unless I had full script approval. And I wrote half the scripts and they sucked. That'd be so great to just shoot some scenes today with Jeff Goldblum. Absolutely.
因为我在合同里写了。再说一次，这是我经纪人的才华。除非我有完整的剧本审批权，否则他们不能拍这部电影。我写了一半剧本，它们烂透了。如果今天能和杰夫·高布伦拍几个场景，那该多好啊。绝对的。
Right? And just put it on the internet? That'd be a lot of fun. You want to know one of the most thrilling things in my career? Speaking of that. And then we got to go. Oh, you got to go?
对吧？然后把它发到网上？那会很有趣。你想知道我职业生涯中最令人兴奋的事情之一吗？说到这个。然后我们得走了。哦，你得走了？
No, after that. You have a hard out. You have a hard out. People are really tough about that. I have a hard out. Yeah. No, I do. Yeah.
不，在那之后。你有硬性截止时间。你有硬性截止时间。人们对此真的很严格。我有硬性截止时间。是的。不，我有。是的。
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm very busy. I have to go home and paint and play the guitar. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm busy. No, I sit at home and stare at the wall, and Beth looks at me. She's not allowed to leave the house. Will you go home tonight and just turn on the TV? Oh, yeah, I've got the advanced copy of next week's Bachelorette.
哦，是的，是的，我很忙。我得回家画画和弹吉他。是的，是的，是的，是的。我很忙。不，我坐在家里盯着墙看，贝丝看着我。她不被允许离开房子。你今晚回家会直接打开电视吗？哦，是的，我有下周《单身女郎》的预先拷贝。
Oh, no way. I cannot. Do you watch traitors? Do you watch traitors? I know. Bachelor. I'm Bachelor Nation all the way. Anybody else with me? Look, Jimmy Fallon's with me. Bradley? Sure. Well, these people have a life. I love it. Bradley, you do not. Amanda loves it.
哦，不会吧。我不能。你看《叛徒》吗？你看《叛徒》吗？我知道。单身汉。我完全是“单身汉国度”的粉丝。还有谁跟我一样？看，吉米·法伦跟我一样。布莱德利？当然。嗯，这些人有生活。我喜欢。布莱德利，你没有。阿曼达喜欢它。
He does not watch it. Bradley watches Bachelorette. That's the secret. He doesn't want anyone to not. All right. Yeah, he loves it. Um, what time is he? It's time for you to go. 6.30. You were, yeah, we're going to be over. We've taken it way too much. Way too much of your time. You're very kind of drive. By the way, and I feel we were success. Yes. This is a great rehearsal. Oh my God. We're going to record. Honestly. Everybody
他不看。布莱德利看《单身女郎》。那是秘密。他不想让任何人知道。好吧。是的，他喜欢。嗯，几点了？是你该走的时候了。6点30分。你，是的，我们要超时了。我们占用了你太多时间。太多你的时间了。你开车很客气。顺便说一句，我觉得我们成功了。是的。这是一次很棒的排练。天哪。我们要录音了。老实说。大家
take a nice break. We'll record in about 20 minutes. What do you mean? Great rehearsal. What are you recording? Tell me. Is the show actually over? Do I leave and then you keep talking? We're going to leave and we're going to keep to, we're going to talk about you a little wrap up. Yeah. A wrap up? Yeah. We're going to talk about how great you are once you leave. Maybe I should listen in. I'll sit here. I won't
休息一下。我们大约20分钟后录音。你什么意思？很棒的排练。你们在录什么？告诉我。节目真的结束了吗？我离开然后你们继续聊？我们要离开，我们要继续，我们要聊聊你，做一个总结。总结？是的。我们要聊聊你离开后你有多棒。也许我应该听听。我就坐在这儿。我不会
say at work. Go ahead. Let me hear what you guys do. And I'll tell you what I'll do. But here's, that's, but Here's the thing, but you got to be... Every once in a while, every once in a while, interrupt, and I'll just go, that's not good radio, or that's really good radio. Do you mind if we cut your mic? Not at all. I was a judge on America's Got Talent.
说在工作。继续吧。让我听听你们做什么。我会告诉你我会做什么。但这是，那是，但这是重点，但你得……偶尔，偶尔，打断一下，我会说，那不是好的广播，或者那是很好的广播。你介意我们关掉你的麦克风吗？一点也不。我曾是《美国达人》的评委。
I know, fantastic. The only reason I watched it. So, by the way, the guy who did the warm-up today, they had a warm-up. O's. Yeah, O's. I wanted him to win the entire season. He did not win that season. He should have.
我知道，太棒了。我唯一看它的原因。所以，顺便说一句，今天做暖场的那个人，他们有暖场。O's。是的，O's。我希望他赢得整个赛季。他没有赢得那个赛季。他本应该赢的。
He's fabulous. He's amazing. He's phenomenal. Ose Perlman. You know what you can... A name built for show business. Here's what you can do While you're being quiet
他太棒了。他太神奇了。他太非凡了。奥斯·珀尔曼。你知道你可以……一个为演艺圈而生的名字。这是你可以做的，当你安静的时候，
And pretending that you're not here when we're doing that No, I'm not going to do it If I have to be completely quiet, I'm not doing it All right, you can talk a little bit But I want you to think about You might be, we might embarrass you if you stayed and heard How much we were going to praise you You can I say something about you guys
假装你不在的时候，当我们做那个的时候，不，我不会做的。如果我必须完全安静，我就不做了。好吧，你可以说一点点。但我希望你考虑一下，如果你留下来听到我们打算如何赞美你，我们可能会让你尴尬。我可以谈谈你们吗？
Yeah, okay This is going to hurt It's got to be good Thank you for having me Thank you Thank you. I'm very excited that you're part of the serious XM fans So are we are here
是的，好的。这会很伤人。这得是好的。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢。谢谢。我很高兴你们是 Sirius XM 粉丝的一部分。我们也是。
I wish you a lot of success Thank you Not too much success but a lot of success Sure And, no, seriously, it's great to have you guys in the family. Thank you for blessing us into it and by doing this. I understand the serious stock is going to go over $2.90. Now that you guys are here.
祝你们成功。谢谢。不要太成功，但要很成功。当然。而且，不，说真的，很高兴你们加入这个大家庭。谢谢你们通过这样做祝福我们。我知道 Sirius 的股票会超过2.90美元。既然你们来了。
God bless, I can't wait. All that stock, I'm going to be so wealthy. You guys, please help us thank Howard Stern. Great Howard Stern. Thank you, everybody. I can't get out of my chair. Howard Stern, keep it going. Keep it going.
上帝保佑，我等不及了。所有的股票，我会变得如此富有。你们，请帮我们感谢霍华德·斯特恩。伟大的霍华德·斯特恩。谢谢大家。我起不来椅子了。霍华德·斯特恩，继续保持。继续保持。
The one and the only. The king of all media. Radio, podcast, television, film. He is the king of all media. They had to raise the ceilings of the talk house just for him. All right. That was surreal for me. I've never met him.
独一无二的。所有媒体之王。广播、播客、电视、电影。他是所有媒体之王。他们不得不为他提高谈话室的天花板。好吧。那对我来说太超现实了。我从来没见过他。
I know, you know, I didn't ever get to talk to. Was he what you thought he was going to be? Yeah, I was really, really nervous. I was really nervous. Was he what you thought he was going to be? Yes, I thought that... How was he different than you thought he was going to be? I didn't know he was going to be so relaxed and easy to talk to, yeah.
我知道，你知道，我从来没能和他说话。他是你想象中的那样吗？是的，我真的很紧张。我真的很紧张。他是你想象中的那样吗？是的，我想……他和你想象中的有什么不同？我不知道他会这么放松，这么容易交谈，是的。
Right? I thought he was going to be like, so what do you guys got? Let's see what you guys got. And he wasn't like that at all. No. Because he's the king of all of it. But he was also, he's incredibly generous and empathetic
对吧？我以为他会像，那么你们有什么？让我们看看你们有什么。他根本不是那样。不。因为他是这一切的国王。但他也是，他非常慷慨和富有同情心，
and probably knows that we're nervous and we're dumb. And we have a new show and he's the king. That's why I have 75 cars. We had a tremendous amount of candor. I was very, right? Immediately he took the reins and helped us and he started talking. And you wrote so many questions because you were so nervous. Seriously.
可能知道我们很紧张，我们很笨。我们有一个新节目，而他是国王。这就是为什么我有75辆车。我们有大量的坦诚。我非常，对吧？他立即掌握了主动权，帮助了我们，他开始说话。你写了这么多问题，因为你太紧张了。说真的。
Sean was upstairs and we're like, what the fuck? It's an hour. Yeah. Just like writing. Any questions you didn't get to that we should listen to? Tons.
肖恩在楼上，我们就像，什么鬼？这是一个小时。是的。就像在写。有什么你没来得及问，我们应该听听的吗？很多。
No, anything you're really pissed you didn't get to. Let's see. I mean, we talked about a lot of, I want to talk about Italy a little bit more and like his vacation. Like what's his ideal vacation?
不，有什么你真的很生气没来得及问的吗？让我们看看。我是说，我们谈了很多，我想多谈谈意大利，还有他的假期。比如他理想的假期是什么？
We'll bring Jimmy on and talk about that. Okay. Anyway, so I love him though. I've been a huge fan. And by the way, I didn't share with you guys the first time. What are you looking at? Nothing.
我们会请吉米来谈谈那个。好的。总之，我爱他。我一直是个超级粉丝。顺便说一句，我第一次没跟你们分享。你在看什么？没什么。
I'm just trying to think. I'm just trying to think. I am. I am. So the first time... Can you feel it coming? Yeah, he starts to work on a buy. So you can see his brain.
我只是在想。我只是在想。我是。我是。所以第一次……你能感觉到它要来了吗？是的，他开始工作了。所以你可以看到他的大脑。
You can see it in real time. And he teased himself up for it. Right. So the first time... But it's too early to do it now. We're still doing wrap up. We're wrapped up. We're wrapped up.
你可以实时看到它。他为它做好了准备。对。所以第一次……但现在做太早了。我们还在做总结。我们总结完了。我们总结完了。
We're ready to go. And we got jelly roll coming up, which is so exciting. Oh, yeah. Oh, so here's a bud. So the first time I was ever here in the Hamptons was only like two, three years ago. And that was the first time ever. And I stayed with Will at his house,
我们准备好了。我们有 Jelly Roll 要来，这太令人兴奋了。哦，是的。哦，所以这是一个芽。所以第一次我来汉普顿是在两三年前。那是有史以来第一次。我住在威尔的房子里，
which is not very far from here. Okay. And this is going to be terrible. This is going to be horrible. Dude. And Will lived so close, so I was just going to ask, Will, did you, today, did you drive yourself over here? Did you ride your...
离这儿不远。好的。这会很糟糕。这会很可怕。伙计。威尔住得这么近，所以我正要问，威尔，你今天，你是自己开车过来的吗？你是骑你的……
Bye! Bye, bicycle! Bye. Jesus Christ for the live show. Sorry about that, guys. But the interview was fun. Was it not? It was really fun.
再见！再见，自行车！再见。天哪，为了现场直播。抱歉，伙计们。但采访很有趣。不是吗？真的很有趣。
Hey! Thank you guys for coming. Thank you so much for coming, you guys. We're going to stick around for jelly roll. Bye. Stick around for jelly roll. Thank you guys. And let's go on for jelly roll.
嘿！谢谢你们来。非常感谢你们来，伙计们。我们要留下来等 Jelly Roll。再见。留下来等 Jelly Roll。谢谢你们。让我们继续 Jelly Roll。
Enjoy some jelly roll. Yeah, jelly roll. Please stick around for jelly roll. Yeah, jelly roll is performing out there. We're so excited. Thank you, guys. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by
享受一些 Jelly Roll。是的，Jelly Roll。请留下来等 Jelly Roll。是的，Jelly Roll 在外面表演。我们太兴奋了。谢谢你们，伙计们。Smartless 是100%有机的，由
Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbicob, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbicob 和 Michael Grant Terry 手工制作。Smartless。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。